Fitness this morning it's a Jeremy
Farrow who's joining us online
so Jeremy could you be sworn please or
give the affirmation if you follow the
instructions from the Usher good morning
I'm ayusha this morning can you hear me
yes good
um if you would like to repeat after me
I understand you're taking the
affirmation is that correct correct okay
repeat after me please I do solemnly
sincerely and truly
I do solely sincerely and truly declare
and affirm
if they're in confirmed affirm affirm
now the evidence I shall give at the
evidence I shall give shall be the truth
shall be the truth the whole truth the
whole truth I'm nothing but the truth
and nothing but the truth thank you
could you provide your full name please
Jerry James Farah
so Jeremy thank you for joining us this
morning
may I commence please with your
qualifications
you trained I believe in medicine with
postgraduate
training in London Chichester Edinburgh
Melbourne Oxford and San Francisco you
have a default PhD from the University
of Oxford
you were a director of the Oxford
University Clinical Research Institute
at the hospital for tropical diseases in
Ho Chi Minh City in Vietnam from 1996 to
2013.
2013 you were director of the welcome
trust and from May 2023
have you been the chief scientist at the
World Health Organization
yes all correct
and
are you giving evidence today in your
personal capacity as opposed to
a representative of the World Health
Organization
yeah it's very important I hear totally
in my personal capacity World Health
Organization or indeed previous lives at
uh contrast either
throughout your professional career
served as a chair on a multitude of
advisory bodies for governments and
Global organizations
were you the founding chair in fact of
the World Health Organization r d
blueprint
um entity or body and the founding
director of the international severe
acute respiratory and emerging infection
Consortium
Isa Ric
correct
and have you received a plethora
from a number of governments institutes
and entities
thank you
could I commend police sir Jeremy by
asking you some questions about
the United Kingdom influenza strategy
document the 2011 strategy about which a
great deal of evidence has been received
by milady's inquiry are you familiar
with that 2011 strategy for influenza
pandemic
yeah thanks very much can I just start
as well by
just reaching out
with the greatest support for those who
have lost lives during the covet
pandemic affected by the pandemic
families that are still affected and
those with long covid and particularly
also for healthcare workers around the
world too
put their lives at risk in order to help
all of us
um
the influenza strategy I think referring
to 2011 at 2011 I was living and working
in in Vietnam and so I was not directly
involved in the development of the
strategy
um but it was Lessons Learned indeed
after the H1 M1 pandemic of 2009 and so
I was peripherally involved in parts of
it and also in the Academy of Medical
Sciences review of how clinical trials
and evidence and data could be gathered
in the context of epidemics and
emergencies so peripherally involved in
that strategy was there a general
awareness of the importance of the
strategy to the United Kingdom's
pandemic preparedness for influenza
I think if you go back
um bear in mind I I've never worked
directly within government I'm sure
there are better people than me about
talking about how that was perceived in
government but if you go back to the
government risk registers over the
over the years then pandemic influenza
would have been in the top risk of many
of those risk registers
um I do think coming out of
2009 that there was a issue with a sense
and this actually is true after many
epidemics I sincerely hope it's not true
after this pandemic that actually 2009
H1N1 was not quite as bad as people
thought and there was a danger globally
including in the UK of a sort of child
that cries wolf and that actually these
were less of an issue than perhaps they
would I I think that did influence
thinking uh after 2009 and mobile built
into why influenza as a pandemic uh drop
down risk registered around the world
after 2011. there have been a number of
references in the course of evidence to
to the possibility the degree of
complacency was engendered by the H1N1
swine flu pandemic because it was
by the nature of these things relatively
mild would you agree
yeah I do agree I I was in Mexico as
part of a who group in May of 2009 2009
sorry
um in May of 2009 the city of Mexico in
four hospitals within a square kilometer
were full of mostly young people with
very very severe influenza and for many
uh of us who have been concerned that
remain concerned that one of the
greatest risks is an influenza pandemic
of some ilk going back to 1918
um it was entirely appropriate in my
view in 2009 to raise the flag that this
was going to cause a major Global
problem in reality as you rightly say
the severity of H1N1 in 2009 was less
than expected and therefore I think
there did come a degree of complacency
that actually the world was safer
against an influence than influenza
pandemic than perhaps has been
previously thought and there was a lot
of criticism at the time about things
like stockpiling of the drug or Sultana
yeah
um personally I think that criticism was
unwarranted and that actually influenza
remains among with others but remains
one of the greatest risks to humanity
and as we now watch h5m1 pandemic in
animals circulate around the world in an
unprecedented way influenza is never
going to go away as a threat to humanity
thank you so Jeremy whilst you give
evidence could you
could you slow down a little we we
obviously want to hear what you have to
say and it's important that your
evidence is recorded by our hard-working
stenographer and it's quite difficult if
you go too fast
no apology apologies it's a nervous um
occasion to be part of
well yeah
it won't be for very long so Jeremy so
I'm sure you'll survive the
Milady has heard uh considerable
evidence about the inherent
unpredictability
of
respiratory viruses and and therefore
the
inherent unpredictability of of the
characteristics of a
pandemic which may ensue from a a
widespread
pathogenic outbreak
putting it in in blunter terms
it's impossible to know with any degree
of certainty what characteristics the
outbreak may have which viruses
respiratory viruses May eventuate and
and therefore
what one has to guard against
was there a general sense at all as far
as you could tell after 2011.
that there had been a a failure to focus
on in in the government
guidance and the government policy in in
the United Kingdom
on the inherent unpredictability of
respiratory viruses and therefore on on
the risks of a non
influenza pandemic
yeah I think that would be true in the
UK I think it would be true globally as
well
um if you go back in the last 20 years I
mean I started working on emerging
infections in 1999 with an outbreak of
something called Nipa virus in Malaysia
please slow down
your game very fast again you have to
Ideal yourself to go slower than you
otherwise would
if we look from 1999 to 2019 that
20-year period
and just look at the number of regional
or Global events that have led to Major
disruption uh SARS one which I was
involved in in Vietnam h5n1 zika MERS
another coronavirus
um the pandemic of 2009 and many others
as well it is clear that we're living in
an age of a pandemic age where as Mike
Ryan at who has said we're living in an
age which is going to have more frequent
and more complex pandemics and yet it is
extraordinarily difficult when
governments are faced with dealing with
the challenges of day-to-day to also put
in place those critical infrastructures
resilience and surge capacity and spare
capacity that would allow to deal with
the unexpected but but inevitable uh
disruptions that are going to occur so I
think in the UK and around the world
despite the warnings of the last 20
years there has been a complacency about
the need to prepare for these sorts of
major disruptive events which go well
beyond Health to the whole of society
and the UK yes was complacent in regard
to planning for that
is it your view that epidemics will
become
more frequent
more complex perhaps and and harder to
prevent and contain
as a result of
the well-known issues of
changing ecology
urbanization climate change and
increased travel and movement of human
beings
yeah you've hit the major features that
I would have outlined absolutely these
are features of the 21st century uh
they're not going to go away it would be
a grave mistake in my view to see each
of these episodes I've I've outlined
some of them but there are more to each
see each one as a discrete episode
they are telling us something far deeper
about how the world is changing
biodiversity loss environment climate
change urbanization trade and travel as
you've said slow down and what I'd like
to for us to move away from
is thinking that this is a discrete
episode which we can put in a box and
think about and think more about the
systemic way that we need to address
these more frequent and more Complex
events if we look at Ebola in West
Africa in 2014.
Ebola virus had not changed people had
not changed what had changed was the
social circumstances in which it
happened not in villages that could be
isolated and quarantined and an epidemic
vote under control quickly but in major
Capital Cities and across borders and
that more frequent and indeed
sociologically more complex epidemics
and pandemics is what we will face in
the future
does it follow sir Jeremy that from the
vantage point of governments
and with a view to the
the necessary and important process by
which risks are identified
assessed
and planned for there must be a much
greater Focus now
both in light of covid and of course
because of the increased General risks
to which you've referred
upon firstly
identifying multiple scenarios as
opposed to just influenza
secondly
focusing additionally on how to prevent
catastrophic consequence
as opposed to managing catastrophic
consequence
and thirdly
thinking more and to a much greater
extent about the necessary
countermeasures that may need to be
deployed
yeah
absolutely
um the first thing I'd say is what you
have before a crisis hits
will to a large extent determine your
ability to respond to it if you have
deep inequalities in your Society if you
have uh uh a large degree of ill health
in terms of health issues if you have
health services which are stretched to
the Limit
um if you have fragmented government
approaches such that each individual
vertical structure considers its area
but there's a challenge to look at the
to all of society perspective then
trying to Cobble together
a horizontal approach an all of
government and all of society approach
in a set of vertical systems is
extraordinarily difficult and tabletop
exercises will get you so far
but you need to be working in those
systems all the time if you want those
systems to work when a crisis hits and I
think we need to think more strongly
about how totally disruptive all of
society events of which this is a good
example will be dealt with at a
cross-government whole of society
approach rather than just as a single
Ministry approach
a a vital component in the whole of
society approach is of course having
adequate
scientific advice
as well as and alongside a adequate and
sufficient research base
could I focus firstly please on on the
issue of the scientific advisory
networks which are available in the
United Kingdom
you were a member of sage the
the stand up
that is a committee which has stood up
in the event of emergencies in relation
to zika and Ebola is that correct
correct
and have you had extensive experience
throughout your long career or dealing
with the the scientific advisory
structures in the United Kingdom Beyond
Sage
yes
evidence
was given by Professor sir Chris witty
that the
the UK science advisory system whilst
complex and not perfect is considered to
be one of the stronger ones
internationally would you agree
yes
what must be done to ensure that that
remains the position in terms of
resourcing or funding or a continuing
focus on understanding the vital
importance of scientific advice
so I would agree with those comments and
I've been involved
um in some of your introductory remarks
with a number of other governments
around the world
um of all economic levels of growth and
and depth of scientific background
my view is is that the construct of
having a a chief Scientific Advisor
in every Ministry
close to the minister close to the
system close to the senior civil
servants not just structured in a crisis
but they're every day
and learning to bridge the cultural and
language complexity that is there within
different disciplines and different ways
of working and different educational
backgrounds and everything else building
that structure to be permanent to be
functioning all the time and critically
providing value and utility to a
government Machinery all the time is I
believe critical and I've argued with
many other countries I'll argue
discussed with many other countries that
actually the UK system of scientific
advice in every Ministry brought
together under a chief scientist uh
networked together providing Mutual
support to each other is absolutely
critical must be maintained must be
strengthened the very best people in
science should be encouraged to go into
it and on a rotational basis so that
they can retain their scientific
expertise and skills and then Network
together through the chief scientist
that to me is the best system in the
world and should everything should be
done to maintain it not for crisis time
but for all the time to deal with the
day-to-day issues as well as be able to
respond when a crisis inevitably hits
it's plain so Jeremy that
in the particular context of dealing
with the covid pandemic
sage and the scientific advisory
structures in the United Kingdom
government
Drew to a very large extent of course
upon biomedical expertise
because of the need to consider at speed
and in very difficult circumstances that
the consequences of societal measures
social restrictions mandatory
quarantining and so on and so forth
it may be the case that there was a an
absence of sufficient expertise from
non-biomedical professionals that is to
say economists and behavioral scientists
or social
scientists
and
um experts not from the world of Health
and and not from the world of of science
but but from the social sciences
would you agree with that from your
experience of sage do you think that it
is in a general sense sufficiently
diverse
so I would agree with some of that but
not all of it
um firstly I think that Sage is often
seen as the names officially on the sage
list which I think counts to 30 or 40
people or so
behind that there were hundreds of
people involved and particularly on some
of the areas you mentioned there uh
Behavioral Science for instance I think
the input into the behavioral scientists
into Sage from throughout my time on
stage I thought was of the very highest
quality
um where I think where I do agree with
you
is that there was no there were two
things lacking in my view one is the
sage
Health Public Health Behavioral Science
perspectives on the pandemic uh were not
mirrored with other equally transparent
and debated issues that brought the
whole of the society elements together
and I believe I've never been in
government but I believe that a better
approach would have been to have a sage
that focuses on its errite expertise
definitely including Behavioral Science
International perspective ethics many of
the things you mentioned but that would
be mirrored in my view through the
cabinet office with a similar
transparent expert group that would
consider other aspects that are
absolutely critical to in all of society
response I think if you are Sage to do
all of that it would become huge
unwieldy and wouldn't be able to have
the clarity given in mind that sabra's
meeting at some point every 24 or 48
hours so personally I would do that
through the cabinet office but have
equal transparency with elements that
considered other aspects Beyond the
health agenda and the second thing I
would suggest and I was part of this in
a U.S group is that there is outside the
sage system but linked to it in a
constructive way if you like a red team
a red team that would have access to
other the same information but would be
able to constructively challenge their
thinking from the outside and wouldn't
be within the room at the same time I
thought that worked extremely well when
I was part of a similar Enterprise in
the United States and I would like to
see that set up Independence age I think
tried to do that but unfortunately for
reasons others can debate sometimes it
became more confrontational than perhaps
was constructed
a red team would plainly be in a
position to challenge Orthodoxy do you
mean
Orthodoxy on the part of the government
or Orthodoxy or alleged Orthodoxy on the
part of the scientists in Sage or a
mirror group who who I think I should
tell you have described themselves in
this inquiry in various terms such as
being self-correcting or on another
occasion as being licensed dissidents
the do scientists need to be challenged
in that way or or is this a point made
more directly against
um administrators and
government employees
science absolutely has to be challenged
and I and I think uh unfortunately I'm
not aware that that beyond the summaries
been released uh I think at the The
Heist of Patrick Valance uh crucially uh
it's a shame that actually Sage wasn't
recorded in some ways because I think
within the sage discussions that I was
always part of there was a very high
degree of the challenge but to have an
outside group a red group that just puts
in questions have you thought about this
have you thought about that have you
considered that you are not part of that
of that formal group I think
my inexperience of that is from the
United States and there I I thought it
was very helpful to be able to do that
it doesn't diminish The Authority or the
voice of sage uh but it would give you
some of that external challenge uh I
think within the cabinet office uh to me
that is where the political challenge or
is this the right thing to do closing
schools closing economies whatever it
might be should be held but I think
those need to also to be transparent in
the same way that Sage was with its
minutes and summary so that people can
actually as a public can actually
challenge those assumptions as well all
right Mr Casey are you going further
into the mirror group no I was going to
move to the questions specialist can we
just just have a brief summary of what
sir Jeremy means by the the mayor of
which experts what how would it work yes
so so generally a few moments ago in in
response to a question for myself as to
whether or not the Constitution
the the makeup of sage was sufficiently
diverse
you suggested the possibility of a
mirror group not not as part of sage
itself because it would become too
unwieldy and too large to be convened as
speed and in very difficult
circumstances but but a separate
committee comprising
um experts uh Specialists from different
professional walks of life could you
expand on that you referred to
social scientists economists and and
others
is there any more that you want to say
about that in terms of its composition
well I think the social scientists and
behavioral scientists were absolutely
fundamental to Sage itself so so I I
certainly
but I think um a group outside of what I
call a red team that was able to uh
throw in questions into Sage have you
thought about this have you thought
about that some of that happened
informally
um through things like in the UK the
Royal Society Academy medical Sciences
etc etc and and obviously in Malay and
scientific literature but I I having
been parts for some time in the U.S of
that red Group which brought together
yes epidemiologists biomedical people
social scientists economists people
thinking outside the box that was
helpful I think in terms of uh the US
approach to this which I have to say
I believe was not as well constructed
and organized as was Sage would be my
view having seen both operating so those
Specialists scientists and professionals
are in terms of Their Own
professional qualifications mirror
images of the constituent parts of sage
they're not they're not from other walks
of
uh professional life that they are there
to to challenge if you like the members
of sage on their own turf
no no I I wouldn't no sorry let me
clarify I think in that sort of red
group you could easily have
um a a broader sector of society Civic
society industry uh people yes with
extra B's an understanding of Public
Health but also others who would bring a
different perspective right
so Jeremy can I ask you now about your
experience please of some of the the
more specialist scientific committees
concerned with pathogenic outbreaks
have you had dealings over the years
with uh has the human animal infections
and risk surveillance committee or acdp
the advisory committee on dangerous
pathogens or on the now abolished netany
are those
committees although you weren't in
government
with which you've had any experience
no I was not part of any of those the
the the greater experience I had
um was actually outside the UK as you
mentioned
um being the founding chair of the who r
d blueprint advisory and who committees
and the other governments but I was
never involved in any of those that you
mentioned there all right
you've referred in the course of your
evidence to the growing risks of
pathogenic outbreaks particularly of the
viral respiratory kind and to the
growing risks generally because of
changes in our environment and our way
of life
to what extent is it essential to meet
those
continuing and growing risks that we
maintain as a country capability that is
to say the
medical
scientific and social
weapons at our disposal to meet
a future pandemic
so I started off by saying what you have
before a pandemic or any crisis hits
makes such a huge difference there are
many things to question and Challenge
and that's the role of the public
inquiry in terms of the pandemic
but I think we can only celebrate
the remarkable
scientific and by scientific I mean the
broad science it's contribution to the
pandemic in the UK and around the world
um that you can't turn that on in a
crisis
we didn't make a vaccine in 12 months
we made a vaccine because for years
before
all governments in the UK of any color I
would argue as well the welcome trust
the charitable sector philanthropy have
invested in basic science in people in
teams and institutions and if you look
through the development of the Oxford
astronomica vaccine if you look at Cog
UK building off years of work at the
welcome genome Center if you look at the
recovery trial
if you look at when local authorities
and others through Public Health got
involved in their communities through
ownership and knowledge of those
communities
those were absolutely World leading
those are the results of Decades of
investment in fundamental science and
its translation a brilliant regulator an
HRA now and when it was part of the EMA
is one of the world's if not the world's
best regulator they were critical
understanding ethics
so this infrastructure in the UK is
something the UK should be incredibly
proud of must maintain and has a
critical role to play internationally
is that a capability which
is that a capability without which it is
impossible to scale up
the necessary medical and clinical
responses in the event of a pandemic is
that something which must be maintained
because without it we would not have the
building blocks to be able to to mount a
defense
in the event of a pandemic
absolutely agree with that
um as I say the vaccine was not made in
a year
um if you don't maintain that capacity
and if that capacity isn't valued isn't
funded is not providing value and
utility all of the time we should
remember that the Oxford AstraZeneca
vaccine came off a team uh Sarah Gilbert
and the Pollard and many others have
been working on those vaccines they've
been working on typhoid vaccines they've
been working on meningitis vaccines and
were able to Pivot the recovery trial
built off years of investment
particularly from the National Institute
of Health research and the clinical
trials capacity
these are absolute jewels in the UK's
Crown they could pay in my view a bigger
role internationally but you have to
maintain them every Monday every Tuesday
and you have to Value them and they must
provide value either in enhancing
knowledge and our understanding of the
world or in translation into products
countermeasures for people in a pandemic
if we do not retain that science
specific infrastructure then the UK will
be woefully underprepared to deal with
today's challenges and tomorrow's
inevitable epidemics
does that infrastructure include
matters such as having sufficient
Laboratory
services for example to be able to scale
up
Mass diagnostic testing in the event of
a
new pandemic and and perhaps a different
testing device
what what sort of
laboratory infrastructure is required to
be able to provide that building block
to enable us to scale up in the next
Crisis
the testing capacity in the first three
months of 2020 in the UK
was woefully inadequate
it wasn't possible to scale that up at
the speed that was required and testing
got way behind the speed of the epidemic
and in epidemics and pandemics
there is no point saying we're quicker
than we used to be if you're slower than
the speed of the epidemic and if you get
behind that curve you'll really struggle
to catch up uh remembering that
exponential growth doubling time every
two days means even 48 hours later
you've lost you've got behind the curve
and the data you have today is in the
rear view mirror it's what happened
yesterday that you're seeing not what
happened today so unless you have that
diagnostic capacity I would personally
like to see a much closer
interrelationship between what we call
Public Health Public Health Laboratories
uh clinical and NHS facilities and the
broad and very strong research
environment in the UK often these are
almost competing with each other rather
than seeing themselves as part of a
common approach and I think to forge
together Public Health Laboratories
local authorities hospitals and clinical
facilities general practice primary care
and the research Endeavor and make sure
that those are working together outside
depending like anchor much better work
together in a pandemic would be a huge
progress in terms of our ability to have
the resilience in the future
so drawing those threads together so
Jeremy would you agree that
both in terms of research capacity but
also infrastructure
Laboratories technicians and the like
yes I'm sorry I'm quite finished it's
vital that
capability is maintained for both uh for
for not just
diagnostic testing
but antivirals and also vaccines to
which you've referred so if this is a
capability which must be maintained
across the board for those three pillars
if you like of
pathogenic outbreak response
yeah I I would actually add to that the
social science Behavioral Science must
be integrated as part of that not some
separate
thing that goes on in other
conversations
but we must maintain that all the time
the only way to maintain it and if we're
not to repeat the lessons of all of the
epidemics I mentioned at the start the
only way we can maintain this is if it
is integrated into services and health
provision prevention and treatment every
Monday every Tuesday every week every
month because after every previous
epidemic after Ebola the world said
never again we must build these
capacities and sadly one or two or three
years later the pandemic hasn't happened
and they start to be cut so my view is
instead of creating yet more vertical
structures
that will somehow be there when a
pandemic strides build it into systems
the reviews every day people are using
them they provide value to communities
and then they can pivot when it's
necessary if we look at Cog UK as a good
example established by Sharon peacock it
was building off years of Public Health
interest in genomics and the welcome
trust genome Center and institutes like
the creek Edinburgh Glasgow Manchester
and others biobank these are critical
infrastructures they're providing value
and utility all of the time and they
have critically the people who can pivot
when necessary we must not lose this
capacity
turning now finally to
to a more administrative or governmental
angle
and the issue of countermeasures
is it your view that
further work is also required to be done
in terms of thinking about evaluating
working out the consequences of
the the policy interventions
with which we're now all only too
familiar such as
quarantining social distancing
the efficacy of face masks
airport screening and so on all of which
of course came very much into Focus
during covid
but perhaps have not been developed in
terms of the thinking as far as they
they might be
yes I do agree with that and
having listened to some some previous
interventions uh and the concern that
everything was based around the
potential fluid pandemic and no other
thinking the things I would sound that
flu remains
the number one biggest risk
um but we should be Thinking Beyond flu
uh in terms of a crisis management
system that would be agnostic to what
the event was and it could be
respiratory most likely it could be
sexual it could be through the
gastrointestinals there's all sorts of
scenarios and instead of getting plugged
into a single outcome which we feel
comfortable with perhaps more important
just to think whilst we will focus on
flu because it's hugely important and is
the most the highest risk and it remains
so but nevertheless we must have a
system which allows us actually to cope
with whatever is thrown at us and have
the resilience and the spare capacity
and not the whole system stretched to
its very limit in order not to be able
to respond when the in the demand
increases so I would like to think more
broadly more like an instant Management
Group than a than a flu specific group
without losing the knowledge that flu
remains a huge a huge risk to us all and
those policy interventions that you talk
about need a discussion at societal
level
the word lockdown none of us had heard
of it before about February or March of
2020 the implications of it are huge and
long-standing we should be able to
debate those in the inter-epidemic
periods and and come to a societal
discussion about what we're going to
prioritize what we're going to protect
and what we may have to do in order to
prevent an event like over 19 happening
again
so Jeremy thank you very much um my lady
I believe you granted permission to
Welsh covid bereaved for an issue or
issues surrounding the question of face
masks to be explored through my own
examination
um so Jeremy
could I return you please to the to the
question of face masks the issue of face
masks and their efficacy
is very much going to be a matter for
consideration in milady's module 2 in
this inquiry
um because of course there was a huge
debate about face masks once covid had
had hit
but in the context of preparedness
may I ask you this
to what extent
pre-covered
was the wearing of face masks an issue
which was
thought about
sufficiently developed
and and Views reached upon
and
an Associated question to what extent
was there pre-covered a scientific
consensus
on the efficacy of face masks
putting aside
however how effective they actually were
so
was there a standing scientific
consensus on the efficacy of face masks
pre-covid and to what extent had
thinking on face masks developed
pre-covered
I think in the UK that consensus did not
exist
um
and the effectiveness as well as the
efficacy of face masks uh I do not
believe in the UK there was a consensus
on that
having spent 20 almost 20 years living
in Vietnam through SARS uh an h5n1 and
then watching very closely and being
very involved in the responses in China
in Korea in Vietnam and Singapore four
countries that had previously dealt with
science one and with other emergencies I
think if you asked there there was a
clear consensus amongst the decision
makers and indeed the scientists and
healthcare workers that face masks had a
role in contributing to the public
health intervention
in public health there is rarely a Magic
Bullet Public Health the analogy of the
Swiss Cheese model of having multiple
interventions is crucial
If You're Expecting face masks to give
you 95 protection against something you
won't get it
but as part of a series of interventions
which includes face marks includes hand
washing and includes clean air and and
and spacing between individuals and then
when you have the counter measures
you're talking about diagnostic tests
treatment and vaccines together they
create a Swiss Cheese model of what how
public health is each one contributes a
percentage none of them on their own
contribute enough to change the dynamic
of a pandemic but together they can have
a very profound impact
and when you talk about countermeasures
often we talk about countermeasures in
terms of Therapeutics and vaccines and
diagnostic testing the countermeasures
need to be seen in the full swiss cheese
model they need to include social
distancing they need to include masks
they need to include hand washing they
need to include in other epidemic
potentials other interventions for
instance in HIV condoms Etc so I think
we would be wiser and the evidence base
on face masks unfortunately was we had
large clinical trials or Therapeutics
the recovery trial we have the vaccine
trials we missed an opportunity during
the pandemic to gather robust strong
prospective data on non-pharmacological
interventions which are a critical
component of any response to an epidemic
and pandemic until you have those
countermeasures that will then change
the course of the pandemic so what I
would plea for is we don't see
countermeasures just to something you
inject into somebody's arm or you take
as a tablet but we see countermeasures
in a Swiss Cheese model of Public Health
which integrates them all and we find
the evidence for how they work on their
own and we find that evidence for how
they work together
so Jeremy thank you very much indeed so
Jeremy thank you very much indeed for
your help it's been extremely
interesting and we're very grateful to
you thank you I wish you the very best
with the public inquiry
um and offer all the support we can to
it the lessons must be learned and we
must never be there again thank you
my lady I think that we can proceed to
the next witness straight away if
somebody would be good enough to sever
the link with sir Jeremy we'll return to
the witness box
thank you
just before the sturgeon gives evidence
I'd like to apologize to those who were
inconvenienced by the fact we didn't
call Miss Calderwood on Wednesday
morning it was due entirely to
unforeseen circumstances and I can
assure people we gave everyone as much
notice as we could and as we got in in
fact so apologies to anybody
Mr Keith
could the witness be sworn please
I do solemnly
sincerely and truly
clear and affirm that the evidence I
shall give that the evidence as you'll
give shall be the truth shall be the
truth the whole truth the whole truth
and nothing but nothing but the truth
could you give the inquiry please your
full name Nicholas sturgeon
sturgeon thank you for offering your
assistance and providing it to this
inquiry but whilst you give evidence
could you please remember to keep your
voice up so that we may or clearly hear
what you have to say and also for our
hard-working sonographer so
they record your evidence
Excuse excuse me my lady with your
permission would it be possible to see a
few words by way of introduction you may
thank you I am appearing at this public
inquiry for the first time and as the
first minister of Scotland for the
duration of the pandemic I wanted to
take a brief opportunity to offer my
sympathies and condolences to all those
who have suffered as a result of covert
19. the pandemic may be over but for
very many people that suffering
continues to this day and there is not a
day that passes that I don't think about
that secondly I want to convey my thanks
to all those who contributed to the
National Response obviously to our
Health and Care Workforce but to all of
those across the public voluntary and
private sectors and of course to the
general public who did everything that
was asked of them and made extraordinary
sacrifices finally Milady I know do that
every day at the government I led did
our best to take the best possible
decisions but equally I know that we did
not get everything right the learning
from the pandemic is of critical
importance and this public inquiry has a
central role to play in ensuring that
those lessons are learned and therefore
I appreciate the opportunity to be here
before you for the first occasion today
thank you very much
thank you miss turgeon you say the first
occasion because of course
um it's known to my lady but but not
necessarily The Wider world that you
will be giving evidence again before
this inquiry
for the purposes of module two a which
will be the module that would be more
particularly concerned with the response
to the pandemic once of course it had
struck
mrgen you've provided kindly a witness
statement dated I think the 19th of
April 2023 we needn't bring it up but
it's a a witness statement to which you
have appended your signature and a
statement of Truth is that correct
that's correct
you were of course as you've said the
first minister of Scotland but earlier
in your career
you were Deputy first Minister and
cabinet secretary for health and
coincidentally
that was during the swine flu pandemic
which hit the United Kingdom in 2009 is
that correct that is correct and so
you you would become familiar
with the
Exquisite difficulties of dealing with
the onset of a pandemic
uh
on a country and familiar with
governmental response
yes
just to get our bearings that pandemic
h191 as we've heard
was by the
General standards of these things
relatively mild was it not yes indeed my
order thankfully than any of us had
expected at the exit of it there were
some 1500 hospitalizations in Scotland
fortuitously no deaths I believe but of
course there were around about 17 000
deaths globally
there may therefore be a limit as to
what lessons could have been learned
from that milder pandemic
but the Scottish government commissioned
a paper did it not
to review its own response to that
pandemic we did yes and was that a
report or a paper that you yourself
commissioned yes I believe I would have
commissioned that as health secretary at
the time
and may we have please that paper on the
screen one zero two nine three six
it's it's headed
cabinet subcommittee on Scottish
government resilience
influenza h191 pandemic review of the
Scottish government response and it was
a paper by the cabinet secretary for
health and well-being
you were Deputy first Minister and
cabinet secretary for health and
therefore may we presume that was you
um I'd have to check the date of it to
see whether I was still uh Health
secretary in that paper
was produced but I I believe that would
have been me yes
[Music]
it was produced
for two thousand
uh 11 you were cabinet secretary for
health until the 19th of May
2011. I was cabinet secretary for health
in two uh late to 2012. and that would
that would have been me in that case yes
you were a cabinet secretary for health
until the 19th of May 2011 and then you
became cabinet secretary for health
well-being and City strategy thereof
thank you for reminding me
page five
of the report
refers at the bottom of the page to
planning assumptions
respondents recognize the limitations of
modeling however it was felt that it
would have been helpful to have updated
the planning assumptions more quickly to
reflect the picture on the ground
in effect reflecting the most likely
scenario rather than the worst case
scenario
respondents felt it would have been
helpful for the process of testing the
planning assumptions to be more explicit
the planning assumptions which were
published did not hold much weight with
responders on the grants that they did
not reflect what they were experiencing
Ms sturgeon these references to the
planning assumptions
and to
national and local responders views as
to how efficient or how useful that they
were was that a reference
um to the the broad
governmental system by which risks are
assessed
group together
and assumptions made for the purposes of
planning as to how those risks should be
addressed so my reading of these
paragraphs and forgive me I would need
to see these paragraphs in the context
of the whole paper to be certain that
what I'm about to say is correct but
certainly in relation to the second
bullet point there what that seems to me
to reflect is something that was
certainly true in the handling of the
H1N1 pandemic is that the the pandemic
did not unfold in the way that the plans
and the modeling and the reasonable
worst case scenario estimates had
indicated that it would and that had at
relevance I think to what we learned
about the the strengths and weaknesses
of pre-pandemic planning and so my
reading of that is that that was a
statement about the the Gap that opened
up during the the swine flu pandemic
between what the plan told us would
happen and what in reality happened
that issue the Divergence between
risk assessment
plan
identification of response and the
reality of a pandemic
was an issue that continued to bedevil
this area of strategy planning did it
not
yes it did I think that is fear comment
and I also having now in different
capacities as we've been covering been
involved in the response to two
pandemics I to some extent think that
that is an inevitability about that
being a problem that will always exist
to some extent because there is no plan
that will ever
completely replicate what happens in
reality when a pandemic unfortunately it
confronts us
indeed and Page 11
relatedly
in the middle of the page there is this
heading actions to be taken forward as
part of the uk-wide review Into the
influenza A H1N1 response was that a
reference to the review which was
carried out in fact by Dame Deidre Hein
that would have been a reference to the
Heine review yes we'll oversee the work
of the review team through Scottish
government representation on the
reference group we'll consider the
implications for Scotland of the
emerging findings specifically those
relating to and then the bottom bullet
point future iterations of the pandemic
framework
was that reference to pandemic flu
a reference to the then pre-existing
Scottish strategy for dealing with
pandemic flu and also the perspective
the anticipated United Kingdom strategy
for dealing with influenza pandemic
which we'll come to in a moment so I
suspect um that that would have been
effectively both of those things it
would have been a reference to whatever
pandemic flu framework was in existence
at the time the pre-existing Scottish
government one and then what became the
UK wide pandemic food preparediveness
plan in 2011.
thereafter Mr Jones as Milady has heard
um in the course of evidence
under the four nations approached the
United Kingdom
Drew up and disseminated a a new 2011
strategy and that is or became the sole
strategy for dealing with
pandemics and it was of course a
strategy which on his face dealt only
with influenza pandemic
there was a commitment there in that
review by the Scottish government to
keeping future iterations of the
pandemic strategy under review
but to a very large extent that did not
happen did it
11 at four nations plan was not updated
um no for that to have been updated on a
four nations basis would obviously have
required the engagement of of all four
governments
um
in my view and this takes us to the
heart of some of the most important
lessons I learned from the the swine flu
pandemic had that plan been updated I do
not necessarily think it would have
changed substantially I think I heard
Professor sir Chris wittimaker a similar
point to you last week that
a review refresh a different iteration
of that would not have changed
necessarily at the fundamental
assumptions or planning or modeling at
the heart of it in brief the two lessons
that I took from swine flu in relation
to plans uh were firstly and I've
already touched on this the importance
of any plan being adaptable and flexible
when it first confronts reality and in
somebody what happened in swine flu was
that as the the pandemic thankfully
turned out to be milder than we had
anticipated there was a period when the
governments tried to make the pandemic
fit the plan rather than adapt to the
plan to the pandemic so flexibility is
the first point the second point I guess
relates to that is the importance of
whatever it is on the paper in the form
of a plan that is work done to
operationalize and test that plan I'm
sure we'll come on to some questions
around exercise cygnus on a UK basis
over sworn in a Scottish basis to the
extent because it was looking at mayor's
SARS rather than flu exercise Iris and
but the work that was done through these
exercises and the work in Scotland that
was done by local resilience
Partnerships sitting underneath our
regional resilience Partnerships in my
view was more important than having
tweaked versions of a plan that was only
ever going to be a template for the
situation that we ultimately found
ourselves dealing with
as it turned out Mr surgeon the reality
was that
plan the strategy the 2011 document
required not just tweaking and it may
well be that it wouldn't just have
stopped it tweaking had it been
significantly revised it was and has
been described by a variety of witnesses
as holy inadequate
strategically
I do accept
that that there is now a much clearer
understanding as to the the nature and
the degree of the inadequacy of that
document
um so yes and if if I may uh perhaps try
to break that down briefly into two
parts and and perhaps give a little bit
more explanation for my use of the term
tweak
um had the process to update that plan
focused on updating an influenza
repeatedness plan
I can't be sure about this but I do not
believe it would have changed
significantly because it would still
have been a plan dealing with the
potential for a flu pandemic had it been
a process designed to turn a flu plan
into a plan that was looking at a
different range of pandemics that may
have been a more substantive exercise
um in terms of your question do I accept
that the plan was inadequate
um in somebody yes the plan was for a
different type of pandemic than the one
we unfortunately were confronted with
what I would say in addition though is
that that does not mean no part of that
plan was useful in any way because some
of the consequence planning for a
pandemic I mean there are some as we
know and we'll come on to No Doubt today
and in future modules significant
differences with significant
consequences between flu and what we
ended up dealing with in terms of a
coronavirus pandemic but some of the
consequences were similar so I would I
guess push back a little bit against the
notion that there was nothing in the flu
planning that served us any purpose at
all when it came to covert 19.
you would accept I think that there was
no
a plan for non-influenza pandemic at
least on on its own face correct
that is absolutely the case uh that is
not to say that there was no thinking
within governments around known
influenza diseases you know High
consequence uh infectious diseases
exercise Iris which was a Scottish
government exercise looked at that
specifically what there wasn't and I
think this is the significant Gap
um is there was no set plan which as I
say is not the same as saying there was
no thinking into how we dealt with a
pandemic that had features and
characteristics of flu in terms of
transmissibility but also the severity
and the what we came to understand in
terms of the asymptomatic Transit
transmission of covert 19. so if we look
at exercise Iris it was looking at a
mere SARS type incident but not a
pandemic one that was small and and
really contained so I would readily
accept that there was a gap in terms of
the pandemic we ultimately were dealing
with
um but as I say that does not mean the
plan that wasn't please had no utility
at all no and I'm not suggested it had
no utility the plan on its face called
for flexible yeah at application it
called for flexibility it proclaimed the
fact that Viral respiratory pathogenic
outbreaks are by their nature inherently
unpredictable
and therefore that the plan should be
applied to non-influenza pandemics but
there was no development of that
thinking was there in the plan there was
no debate about what those inherently
unpredictable characteristics might
consist of the differences in the
transmission rates or viral load or
severity or incubation period
that's correct that is correct um that
said and I obviously I'm not a
scientific clinical expert in any we
shape or form
but it may have been difficult to
capture the range of possibilities that
you you've just alluded to there in a
single plan I think the other point I
would make about
the utility or otherwise of plans had
the flu plan been reviewed and turned
into something that was looking at
pandemics or the potential pandemics
more widely whether that plan would have
served its purpose would have depended
on the capabilities that Lee underneath
that plan so I'm straying slightly
perhaps into future modules here but for
me the questions in my mind literally
every day are not
so much did we lack a plan but did we
lack the capabilities for dealing with a
pandemic of the nature of covid-19 and
obviously I'm talking there about
contact tracing testing infrastructure
in particular
but you would accept Mr sturgeon that
had the plan focused more plainly more
clearly on
the inherent unpredictably
unpredictability of viral respiratory
pathogens
and their characteristics and identified
that the next pandemic might have
different characteristics to influenza
in terms of transmission rate incubation
period viral load
severity
it is likely there would have been a
much closer and clearer debate about the
necessary countermeasures
for example Mass diagnostic testing Mass
contact tracing
social restrictions quarantining and so
on and that debate was wholly absent
wasn't it from that strategy
and from all the contempreneurs material
at much of that yes I was was absent
from that so I I do think that is is
fair
um and yes I with retrospect and in
hindsight I think we would all have
benefited from much earlier discussion
around some of of these things I suppose
the only point I'm making maybe this
comes from uh too many years in
government not now obviously is I think
that is a real danger
um in putting an over emphasis on plans
that is a that is often
um a tendency in government to say well
we have a plan it sits on the shelf and
so we've done the preparation and it's
what as I think you're putting to me
fairly is what lies underneath that and
had there been a plan that looked at the
range of pandemics other than flu then
yes it is possible that we would have
had a greater discussion around some of
the elements that of course came very
much to the fore when covered struck
the reason I put the question to you Mr
in the way that I did what was to
respond to your suggestion that
the Strategic acknowledged strategic
flaws in the plan may not have mattered
because what matters more is capability
my point you is
had there been a proper development of
the issues of the required
countermeasures
necessary to meet properly identified
risks of non-influenza pandemics in that
document
that capability is likely to have been
better developed by the time covid
struck I I think that is is fear and I I
would accept that um I think it would
come down to how precise some of those
other predictions or models had be bad I
think that is a fair comment to put to
me and
your point about the danger in
government of selecting a plan
in the reasonable expectation that it
will do what it says on the tin and it
will meet the need of
the exigency or emergency which has
arisen
would you agree that
that plan
tended to focus upon managing the
catastrophic consequences of on of a
pandemic influenza as opposed to trying
to prevent those
catastrophic consequences from
developing in the phone um I'm not sure
I do entirely agree with that and again
I'm I'm perhaps straying from your
question being anchored in the flu
preparedness plan and projecting a
little bit to some of the commentary
that's been made around the handling of
of covet
um I suppose you know there's a question
in my mind in the context of a pandemic
what do we mean by prevention I think
there is a question about whether any
single country at a population level
could prevent a stop a pandemic
happening clearly there are measures at
an individual level that people try to
take to prevent themselves getting it
but
in the context of a pandemic it is and I
can only speak for myself and the
Scottish government here it was never
the case when covered struck that we
just accepted as a given that a
reasonable worst case scenario was going
to unfold it was our determination from
the outset to do everything we could and
I think this is what prevention means in
the pandemic context to suppress it to
the maximum the questions uh I think
that are really important for us all to
consider very very frankly is could or
should we have done more to suppress to
the maximum covert but speaking on
behalf of the government eyelid at the
time it was never the case that we
simply accepted there is a level of harm
that is going to be done by this virus
and and we accept that we were always in
fact it became later on one of the
points of difference between the
Scottish and the UK government the
extent to which we were still seeking to
suppress as opposed to live with the
virus um so I don't accept that there
was ever certainly in my mind an
acceptance of a level of harm that we
were you're willing to to have unfold
that was not however my question Mr
sturgeon
my question revolved around
the strategy
and whether you accepted that one of the
unintended consequences of that strategy
was that it tended to
Focus
administrative
concentration on
trying to deal with the consequences of
a catastrophic emergency rather than
preventing to the first place for
example you've already acknowledged that
the absence of thinking on
two main
methods by which catastrophic
consequences can be prevented Mass
diagnostic testing and Mass contact
tracing were wholly absent from this
strategic debate so forgive me if you
thought I wasn't answering the question
I was seeking to try to answer your
question but I perhaps went on to covert
more than the the flu plan I think one
of your your questions which is
reasonable is the flu plan was looking
at flu and so some of what would have
been perhaps in that plan had it been
looking more widely was not there what I
was seeking to address was this notion
either in the flu plan or later in covid
that there was simply an acceptance of a
level of consequence I think I'd forgive
me I can't remember the the precise text
in the the 2011 flu plan but I think
there is commentary in it that
reasonable worst case scenario are not
necessarily thing to accept they don't
take account of the counter measures
that you take to try to reduce that and
so I either in that plan or in the
eventual handling of corvid I
speaking from my own perspective it was
not simply a here's a level of
consequence that we accept that we can't
do anything about I do think and this
goes to your point about Mass testing
and contact tracing the question very
legitimate is could or should we have
done more to put ourselves in the
ability of of suppressing it is also the
case that I don't think for any
responsible government it can ever in a
context like this be either trying to
suppress
or dealing with the consequences you
have to do both and and that is a
feature of the planning as well I'm
going to put that over to module 2A Miss
sturgeon forgive me but but in relation
therefore to the strategy we're appear
to be agreed that the strategy
because it proclaimed its ability to be
applicable to non
influenza pandemics
well whilst it proclaimed his ability to
be flexible and applicable to
non-influenza pandemics simply did not
provide the thinking of the tools
necessary to be able to deal with them
I'm not asking you again about and I'm
not seeking your answer in relation to
how the Scottish government did respond
and what its approach was once it was
struck by the pandemic but in terms of
the strategizing the planning and the
preparedness at a overarching level
that thinking and the development of the
necessary tools was absent from the sole
strategy document that was meant to be
applicable
um we're going to be great I'm sorry oh
yeah take a break every so often the
surgeon for the strong affair would that
be a suitable very suitable thank you
lady but I shall return at half past 11.
all right
foreign
having been harnessed
to the 2011 strategy
Scotland
was of course aware that that strategy
was required to be
refreshed or updated and you are aware
are you not that one of the work streams
which was assigned
to the pandemic flu Readiness board in
London
and to the pandemic flew preparedness
board in Edinburgh
was the job of updating that strategy
and
it never came to pass
that's correct
and
you agree that the reason why never came
to pass was that it was one of the work
streams which was recognized
to be necessary to be done and because
of the diversion of time energy and
resources to the necessary preparations
for a
neutral EU exit it happened to be one of
the the work streams that was paused yes
that is correct
um the prospect of an audio brexit and
the work that was required across all of
the UK governments uh to plan for uh
yellowhammer assumptions it meant that a
significant amount of time energy and
resource was diverted into that from a
range of of other matters and that was
certainly one of the work streams that
suffered from that and we may come on to
this I won't go into detail right now
that is not to say there was not
continued work in the Scottish
government to prepare for a pandemic
although as we've already covered much
of that was in the context of a flu
pandemic
as you've rightly acknowledged and and
as your
then director of safer communities
cabinet
I think I know director of safe
communities Jillian Russell accepts in
her witness statement
a very significant amount of emergency
planning time
was spent on planning for a new
do you exit
and therefore something had to give and
one of the things that had to give was
some of the work
that was meant to be done for emergency
planning
may we ask you to what extent was that
difficult decision
the diversion of resources debated at
cabinet level it's a it's apparent from
a large number of documentation that
the necessary diversion was
ventilated at a competition level was
acknowledged and accepted and and
officials just had to get on with the
job in hand with the resources that they
had
but to what extent was that brought to
your attention for the ultimate decision
as to whether or not that diversion of
resources
away from emergency planning was
appropriate so I I was very aware of the
the necessity to divert resources from
other priorities to plan for and look at
the the potential for a new deal brexit
um it it wasn't the case to the base of
my memory that somebody came to me and
said we need to divert resources from
pandemic preparedness to this but I
would have known that there were many
other aspects of emergency planning that
had resources diverted for them the
Scottish cabinet discussed No Deal
brexit brexit generally and the
potential for a new deal breaker on many
different occasions at brexit obviously
was something that was happening
completely against the the will of the
Scottish government so we were not at
all happy about what we were having to
do but to put it bluntly we had no
choice because had a No Deal brexit
happened and there were periods over at
2019 where that was a distinct
possibility the consequences of that
would have been very very severe the
planning assumptions in yellowhammer
were were grim and extremely worrying so
we had no alternative but to do that
work to the best of our ability and we
have limited resources all governments
have limited resources within emergency
planning we have within that limited
specialisms and skills in particular
areas so it stands to reason that with
so much effort on that there was going
to be less resource available for other
aspects of emergency planning
resources were rediverted from
a number of different parts of the
Scottish government it wasn't I imagine
the resources were only redverted from
civil contingency planning
you had to find the resource and the
time and the energy from somewhere in
order to be able to do the necessary
preparations for a new deal exit there
was probably not and forgive me if I'm
slightly oversimplifying this here but
there would not be many if any areas of
Scottish government work that were not
impacted by the the planning for the for
brexit generally and and a no deal
brexit so in health other than emergency
planning a lot of resource and and
energy looking at some of the supply
chain disruptions the the consequences
for the Health Service Staffing of
ending free movement across the European
Union and education obviously with
universities around the education
program so every part of our work was
impacted by this and it was a matter of
deep and extreme regret and frustration
for us at the time
the risk of a pandemic influenza
was a tier one risk in the United
Kingdom governments
risk register
presumably it was no less no less
greater risk in the Scottish risk
register
it was the greatest it was identified as
the greatest risk facing the nation
in the
plethora of risks which Any Nation faces
so would you agree that the diversion of
resource and money and time from that
issue that area of
planning for the greatest risk which the
country faced the tier one influenza
pandemic risk
was ultimately a
false economy because although
the consequences of a No Deal EU exit
would have been extremely serious and
had to be mitigated
the one area from which he really
couldn't be said the resources should
sensibly be drawn would be the no less
significant error of
pandemic preparedness I don't disagree
with that I think every aspect of brexit
has been false economy if I can put it
well mildly but that's another all
together let me started I'm so sorry
yeah that is a witness box not a soapbox
we cannot allow
with respect to I I think you're asking
me questions here that are very germane
to the whole issue um so yes I think it
was
um deeply regrettable that resources had
to be diverted from any other area of
work and in particular uh pandemic
preparediveness
um I also though would repeat a point I
made earlier on that it was certainly
from the Scottish government perspective
it was not the case that all preparation
around the potential for a pandemic
stopped I would imagine you will ask me
later in the session about exercise
silver sworn that was one of the key
elements of work in different work
strands out of that of course so all of
that was was deeply serious the point
I'm making is that we had little
alternative but to do that the
consequences of a new deal brexit
um compared to what we faced with covert
of course pale into insignificance but
at the time looking at the yellow Hammer
assumptions uh had they come to pass
they would have been severe we were
talking about availability of food and
you know the shops and medicines for the
the National Health Service so we had no
choice but to do that planning I deeply
regret any implications that had for our
emergency planning in other areas thank
you that's very clear
just turning now to
the
the broad issue of the relations between
Scotland and
Westminster in terms of
preparedness planning many of the
recommendations which had come out of
the hind review to which you referred
earlier
insofar as Scotland was concerned in the
divulge the other devault
administrations revolved around
the the need for proper framework for
communication both at CMO level the
chief medical officer level and the dcmo
level
the need for perhaps a health forum
across the United Kingdom in which there
could be a proper informed debate at
that level about pandemic preparedness
and also of course between the civil
services of of the devil Administrations
to what extent do you believe that the
working relationships in relation to
pandemic preparedness worked across the
the default Administration in UK level
I think they worked reasonably well in
in general terms I think they remained
to ad hoc and didn't become as the Heine
review would have recommended more
embeddied in a very systemic way I know
and this was certainly true at the
outset of covert the working
relationship between the four CMOS was
was very good and very strong and
Scotland CMO at the time fed uh lots of
uh information and thinking from those
discussions into the decisions we were
taking
discussions and relationships between
Health ministers would vary I think in
from my perspective over the years often
as will sometimes be the case depend on
the individual's concerned which is more
of a feature when they are at Hawk
Arrangements rather than embedded
overall though I think in the context of
intergovernmental relations at work
around in swine flu and from swine flu
leading up to the beginning of covet I
think relatively speaking they worked
well
presumably an informal system of
communication depends too much on
personal inclination personal relations
and perhaps ministerial whim as to
whether or not the meetings take place
did you ever get to the point where you
where you believed that
that had to be a significant effort made
to formalize those working relationships
or or did it never get to that state
um
I I think it frequently gets to that
stage in various discussions and in this
context
um yes I think it would be better if we
had uh
working relationships that were at more
systemized and embedded and that would
then transcend different individuals
that said processes will not work
however invaded they are if they don't
have good faith and the right mindset
and attitudes behind them so in terms of
the working between the four nations in
this context or indeed any context It's
a combination of all of these things
that is required but certainly more of a
an embedded structure that is then
respected by all of the governments that
play I think would be a step in the
right direction sturgeon how do you get
past I don't know if you heard Jeremy
Hunt come out with a brutally Frank
answer which was that when he was
Secretary of State for health
for being here for England and Wales for
England sorry
um
he found that Party politics got in the
way of the relationship between
ministers for health and the various
Administrations
so I think that can happen and I think
it has happened I also think it's
possible to overstate uh the the extent
to which that happens in my experience
forgive me just briefly to go back to
swine flu I as Scottish Health secretary
at the start of swine flu Alan Johnson
was Health secretary for England then
replaced by Andy Burnham I had a very
good working relationship with both of
those in different political
perspectives at play there so I think if
the attitudes and the mindsets are
correct particularly in the context of a
health emergency political differences
shouldn't get in the way but of course
that is going to depend from time to
time on the different personalities
involved and forgive me I I'm not going
to stray off the the topic here but
inevitably that will be influenced it
shouldn't be but it will be influenced
by The Wider political context at the
time and perhaps brexit has a an impact
there in terms of setting the overall
tone for some of these intergovernmental
relationships
relent your considerable authority to a
review of United Kingdom and National
intergovernmental relations did you not
yes
um post-covered uh there is a there is
now a structure
which provides I think for a a devolved
government Council
for interministerial groups to to meet I
think there's an interministerial
standing committee or some some sort of
committee and a Secretariat
intergovernmental relation Secretariat
do you know whether or not that
committee structure has borne fruit yet
is it something which as first Minister
you attended whilst you're in office
those new arrangements are very much in
their infancy and we're even more in
their infancy while I was still first
ministers I think in in many respects it
remains to be seen the the extent to
which they improve the the overall
working relationship I come back to a
point I made earlier I think
systems and processes are really
important but they will only work if all
of the parties participating in them
participate in the right spirit and
attitude and and that in
intergovernmental relations is often
where it breaks down
um and I've been as first Minister and
for years before that as Deputy first
Minister involved in a range of
different iterations joint ministerial
councils these new arrangements and and
they will work if everybody around the
table is there in the right spirit
the lady had evidence from Oliver dad
and the Deputy Prime Minister about how
but both before but but I think boosted
by the national resilience framework and
its publication by the United Kingdom
government in December 2022 there had
been set up a UK resilience forum
to discuss
important issues relating to cross
United Kingdom
um
resilience and civil contingency
Arrangements
the Scottish government attended the
first UK resilience Forum as did
UK ministers on the 14th of July 2021
but the Scottish government was absent
it's listed as a absent
participant
in May 2022 and February 2023 so it
missed it has simply not attended two of
the three UK resilience Forum meetings
do happen to know why that is so I
I I don't know for certain that it is
the case I appreciate your read but I I
understand there may be some dubiety
about whether we were in fact present on
one of these occasions but that's not
something I can answer for you with
certainty well you were present on the
first meeting the Scottish government's
prison I personally wasn't present I
understand from my own colleagues that
there is some uncertainties to whether
we were present at the second one or no
I know the the minutes suggest that we
wear it but that's not what an issue I
can resolve for you right now that
resilience Forum I think is
um is an important opportunity for the
the four nations to come together it's
remit although again it's a forum in its
relatively early stages it seems to be
similar to perhaps not identical to the
the Scottish resilience partnership
which is also a strategic overview so
certainly the ability to have a
phonations forum that our own
operations can feed into is certainly a
useful one I cannot answer why the
Scottish government I can get that
information for you I can't answer here
why we weren't present if indeed we
weren't present but that is something I
certainly would encourage ministers now
to take part in
thank you
the minutes I should say both the 3rd of
May 2022 and 23 do state in terms that
the Scottish government was holy absent
can I say I wasn't questioning that
particular point
now the exercises Silver Swan
cygnus and an iris
the
exercise signals
exercise was the United Kingdom exercise
delivered by public health England it
wasn't therefore focused
centrally on Scotland Scotland played an
important part and and attended it
and and
members of the Scottish government were
present during the exercise itself
do you recall whilst first minister
debate about the extent to which the
recommendations from exercise cygnus had
been implemented there is evidence I
should say before my lady that on a UK
level
many of the recommendations
were by the time of covid not
implemented holy somewhere in part
implemented some were not implemented at
all some were complete
what was the position with Scotland
so the first part of your question would
I have had an awareness I would have the
general awareness of exercises and the
Scottish government working to implement
recommendations that were relevant to us
I I wouldn't have been closely involved
on a day-to-day basis with that uh in in
detail my understanding is that of the I
think 22 recommendations out of exercise
cygnus at the Scottish government
assessed all of them for their
applicability or relevance to Scotland
yes and and I believe at the time covert
uh struck us there were uh 14 of those
complete and any outstanding
um some of those would have been for the
UK government to take the lead on I
believe one on social care was paused by
the UK government uh due to brexit
something we've already discussed there
was another around pandemic guidance
that the UK government was to take the
lead on but that hadn't been progressed
I think the other point I would make
about this is in relation to both those
uh recommendations that I've mentioned
there would have been analogous
recommendations and silver sworn that
Scotland was pursuing so on yes social
care there was a recommendation there
about social care contracts business
continuity that we had considered
complete and in terms of pandemic
Guidance with one exception which was
updated guidance for Health and Social
care that had been out for consultation
at the end of 2019 but other than that
the recommendations in silver sworn for
updating guidance had been taken forward
in relation to exercise Iris
that was a one-day exercise what was
that a tabletop exercise yes it was and
that was a Scottish exercise yes in in
March of 18. was that the exercise that
was concerned with a assumed outbreak of
MERS yes and what Ms sturgeon was the
outcome of that exercise in terms of the
implementation of recommendation that
was very much ongoing at the time at
covid struck obviously that exercise was
the the latest of the three that we're
referring to right now I think took
place in 2018 there were I think of the
13 recommendations in it there were at
four that had been completed a number
two I think that were ongoing and then
some others were paused when covet came
along for when we look at some of them
for understandable reasons because the
system was dealing with a real pandemic
at that time and it would not have made
sense to go forward in a separate track
with the the recommendations from Iris
but I this is a partly because of when
it happened is the one where at the
outset of covert there were most of the
recommendations it's still outstanding
or more than in the other exercises I
think it's fair to say Mr surgeon that
there were no single work streams which
were of great importance which were
wholly uncompleted so
although there were I think three areas
where work had not been completed other
aspects of those work streams had been
completed are you still referring to
exercise Iris yes yes so in relation to
I think updating guidance in relation to
MERS COV which obviously is not great
um significance perhaps in terms of
dealing with covid certain work to do
with readying NHS boards
to deal with the potential impact of
contact tracing Community sampling
during a hcid outbreak and also
finishing off the fit testing for
particular types of PPE were those the
broad areas that were still outstanding
yes that's correct and some of the the
PPE recommendations around fit testing
initially came from Silver sworn but
there were similar recommendations out
of exercise Iris as well
and then coming back to Silver Swan
which I acknowledged it was before Iris
but the reason I'm coming to that last
is for the importance of one of the work
streams which which came out of Silver
Swan
the
I think of the the the 17
recommendations 13 were considered by
the Scottish government to be complete
but an important area was pandemic
guidance for the Health and Social care
sector
was that ever completed even though
Silver Swan was in 2050. the
Pacific guidance for Health and Social
care had not been completed it was out
for consultation at the end of 2019
um and therefore hadn't been finalized
and signed off the recommendation in
exercise silver sworn around pandemic
guidance though Incorporated more than
that that one piece of guidance and all
of the other
aspects that we took forward had been
completed so NHS standards for
organizational resilience it had been
published and reviewed guidance on
dealing with mass fatalities guidance on
death certification pandemic flu
guidance for infection prevention and
control and pandemic flu Communications
guidance these other bits of guidance
had been completed the one outstanding
part was the response and guidance
documentation for Health and Social care
which was still at the consultative
stage yes
that was an important part of Silver
Swan it wasn't complete by the time of
Iris and it wasn't complete by the time
of covid four years later that's correct
all right
and is that primarily why the auditor
general of Scotland
who reported in February 2021 in the
report NHS in Scotland 2020.
to the effect that
the Scottish government could have been
better prepared to respond to the
covid-19 pandemic
it based its initial response on the
2011 strategy which we've debated
but did not fully Implement improvements
identified during subsequent pandemic
preparedness exercises it was that issue
of
failure to complete the work
done in the adult social care sector
that led to that conclusion I wouldn't
want to speak for the auditor general in
um
seeing what led to those conclusions I
would see my view would be that that
would have been part of it I think the
well I know there were other
issues raised in the audit Scotland
report that you refer to around PPE PPE
availability and distribution so I I
wouldn't
I'm not sure I would agree that was the
only issue that led to those conclusions
but certainly it would have been one of
them perhaps for completeness I should
say that that audit Scotland report also
did comment that the Scottish government
responded quickly to covert when it
confronted us Mr surgeon that is of
course is an issue of response with
which you and I both aware we're not
addressing we're dealing with
preparedness
I may have been a little unfair because
paragraph 46 of that same report
concludes as a priority the Scottish
government should update and publish
National pandemic guidance for Health
and Social care from which we deduce
that that was the era that was
outstanding has that guidance now been
published I do not believe that has yet
been published but you've forgive me
I've not been in the Scottish government
for a few months now there and I think
the audit Scotland report reflected this
there is a real importance in ensuring
that that guidance which had been out
for consultation before covid fully
reflects the learning from covet but Mr
sturgeon that report was issued in
February 2021 uc's being first Minister
on the 28th of March of this year during
that elapse of two years while you were
first Minister was that National
guidance for the Health and Social care
sector published uh no
um I again I I can only give a opinion
here I think from my experience to have
published
guidance without properly assessing some
of the lessons we also commissioned and
established a standing committee on
pandemic preparedness and I think it is
important that the Health Service in
Scotland as I'm sure is the case in the
other nations of the UK has lots of
guidance that it operates within and
that it takes King nice and sort of in
terms of pandemic guidance I think it is
really important that there is a a
proper wholesome exercise to incorporate
properly the the granular as well as
some of the Strategic Learning from the
the covert pandemic and to conclude the
reference to which you've just made
about a standing committee is that the
standing committee on pandemic
preparedness which is a a permanent
Advisory Group which you commissioned it
now sits permanently
comprising scientists experts CMO the
deputy CMO and others
to make recommendations
for
the the better promotion of pandemic
preparedness in Scotland yes and has
that
already has that committee already
issued an interim report I think it did
so in August last year making
recommendations
about various aspects of pandemic
preparedness it issued an interim Port
that I responded to while I was still
first Minister I think it made three
interim recommendations uh one
proposing a center for pandemic
preparedness another relating to the the
data and analytics infrastructure that
we have and in its view should develop
in Scotland
um and a third around how we build and
strengthen scientific advisory networks
both within Scotland and across the UK
and Link into International
organizations as well it is due in
coming months to publish a more
substantive Report with longer term
recommendations as I understand it and
there was a fourth continued innovation
in the sciences and public health
research
like forgive me that was the third one I
was referring to forgive me if that was
a fourth and I've missed the third one
that's all right
Ms sturgeon thank you very much
Melody would you give me one moment I
think I've given provisional permission
to
Scottish covered breathed to ask a
question
I confirm permissions granted Mr amor
[Music]
good afternoon Mr
I have a handful of questions left to
ask on behalf of the Scottish corporate
bereaved in your evidence earlier you
readily accepted there was a gap in
terms of the pandemic you're ultimately
dealing with well that that but that did
not mean the plan had no utility at all
so I'm going to refer you to the Joint
expert report that was provided prepared
for this inquiry on health inequalities
for module one by Professor Sir Michael
Malmo and Professor Claire bambra I
refer you specifically to
inquiry000195843 page zero zero six four
paragraph one four nine I'm not going to
take you through it but to summarize he
concluded that with some exceptions The
Specialist structures concerned with the
risk management in civil emergency
planning did not properly consider
societal economic and health impacts in
light of pre-existing inequalities and
the UK government and the devolved
administrations and relevant Public
Health bodies did not systematically or
comprehensively assess pre-existing
social and economic inequalities and the
vulnerabilities of different groups
during a pandemic in their planning for
risk assessment processes so Mr the
question is do you accept that this
analysis would also apply to the
Scottish government in their pandemic
planning
um in Broad terms yes I would I don't
think that we
efficiently and to use the terms they
are systematically or comprehensively
assessed
socio-economic Health inequalities and
therefore how we dealt with them in the
context of a pandemic so I think I would
accept that again I don't think it is
right to go from there to say there was
no planning and no thought given to that
there again I won't repeat it I think
some of this is is narrated in the
expert report that you're quoting it to
me the work that the Scottish government
had done starting again when I was
Health secretary around the equally well
work culminating in April 2020 in the
establishment of Public Health Scotland
which is actually in an organizational
sense one of the initiatives intended to
build that systemic and comprehensive
approach to in particular Health
inequalities into our planning work
thank you the second question is to what
extent if any do the Scottish government
carry out an equalities and human rights
assessment of its pandemic preparedness
plans
um if I can answer in somebody there and
offer to to seek more information to be
provided because it is a question that
would involve uh looking at lots of
different aspects of of planning the
Scottish government does and will have
carried out different impact assessments
of different aspects of of our planning
both in in preparedness and then as we
went into the the response phase to
covert I don't have all of the detail of
that in front of me right now but I can
through those in the Scottish government
seek to have that provided if that is
helpful thank you that would be helpful
and we would be seeking that information
asking the inquiry to seek that
information and the third question Miss
sturgeon is to what extent if any were
those plans assessed as to how they
would affect the various protected
characteristics in terms of the equality
act 2000 for example age disability
maternity race religion sex and sexual
orientation amongst others so again
um apologies if I'm repeating myself
that would have been part of impact
assessments that would be carried out
routinely on Scottish government work
and planning again I will have to get
you more detail of that in terms of the
the sort of granular information again I
am moving
into the the response phase here but you
will be aware I'm sure one of the things
we did early on in the response phase
was to set up a an expert group on
ethnic minority inequalities in order
that as we went through the response
phase we could make sure that we were
adapting appropriately there but in
terms of the detail of the impact
assessments and protected characteristic
assessments I as I see I will seek to if
the inquiry would find it helpful to
have more information passed to it
that would be helpful those are the
answer of my questions thank you very
much it would be helpful if you could
provide that information mrsion can I
just check were you saying that it's
your understanding the impact
assessments routinely
included consideration of protector
characteristics I forgiving Melody I
wouldn't want to
um
to leave you with that I'm not sure that
that would not be an overstatement so
again I think the information I'm
offering to have provided through the
offices of the Scottish government would
answer that question for you um
certainly that would be involved in
Impact assessments but I wouldn't want
to attach uh more uh relevance to the
word routinely then I feel confident to
give you right now
thank you very much I'm a lady rather
than setting um too great a hair running
it may help Mr Anwar
um if a lady recalls for him that the
evidence of Miss lamb yesterday included
a a section dealing with
the consideration by Scotland of Health
inequalities and my lady will recall
that there was a in the course of
evidence she referred to the auditor
general for Scotland's Report on health
inequalities 2012 equally well 2013 the
NHS Health Scotland's Health
inequalities policy review 13 and then
five Public Health
reports between 2013 and 2022
which therefore provide the basis along
with the public Central quality Duty in
the equality act 2010 for the
consideration of Health inequalities
thank you
thank you very much indeed Ms sturgeon
that's all for today
um next time we meet I suspect we'll be
in Scotland thank you
Miss Blackpool thank you my lady the
next witness is John Swinney
thank you
and the evidence I shall give shall be
the truth shall be the truth the whole
truth
and nothing but the trees
Mr Swinney may I begin by thanking you
for the assistance that you've so far
given to the inquiry and you have
provided a witness statement
um which we can see at one eight five
three five two
thank you and can we go to page 15
please
can you confirm Mr Swinney that that is
signed by you on the 5th of May of this
year and it's true to the best of your
knowledge and belief that is the case
yes thank you very much may we have
permission to publish thank you my lady
we can take that down
Mr Sweeney you held the position of
Deputy first minister in the Scottish
government from November of 2014 until
March of this year is that right that is
courageous you began your political
career as a Westminster MP for the
tayside north constituency from May of
1997 and you were then a member of the
Scottish Parliament first for North
tayside constituency from 1999 to 2011
and then for the perthshire north
constituency from 2011. that is all
courageous you also held the roles of
cabinet secretary for finance and
sustainable growth in the Scottish
government from May 2007 to May 2016.
cabinet secretary for education and
skills from May 2016 to May 2021 and
cabinet secretary for covid recovery
from May 2021 to March 2023 is that all
correct that's all courageous thank you
I'd like to begin by asking you please
about your ministerial responsibility
for resilience because as Deputy first
Minister over the nine year period that
was very much part of your portfolio
wasn't it that's courageous what was the
score scope of ministerial resilience
before I answer the question would it be
possible Melody for me perhaps just to
express at the outset of my evidence my
sympathy to everyone affected by covert
and for the suffering that has been
experienced and also my appreciation to
members of the public and our Public
Service Personnel who've done so much
along with colleagues in the private and
third sectors
sustain recovery
in relation to the question my
responsibility for resilience was held
essentially as an ultimate point of
um responsibility I consider myself to
be in the government responsible for
resilience matters accountable to the
first minister
and it was my role to make sure that
Scotland had in place and effective
resilience Arrangements now that didn't
mean that I did everything because in
one of the introductions to the Scottish
risk assessment for example I meet the
point that resilience has got to be
everybody's business
so all aspects of government have to
think through what are the resilience
risks that are faced in their area of
responsibility
but it was my responsibility to make
sure that all of that was in a stronger
position as it could be for um any
eventuality that we had to face given
that this was but one portfolio of of
many that you would have had your eyes
across in the role of Deputy first
Minister do you feel that you had
sufficient time to be able to devote to
the the subject of resilience
life was always pretty hectic to be
honest in all the ministerial
responsibilities that I carried out and
but I did feel I had adequate
opportunity to provide the Strategic
leadership to resilience issues that
were required but I stress that wasn't
a responsibility that means I had to do
everything I was providing the direction
the strategy the approach to be taken
but oversee motivating colleagues and
all the relevant aspects of the Scottish
government and our partners around the
country to make sure that they were
preparing properly like the the reason
that I ask you that question is and you
may be aware that the inquiry has heard
from Sir Oliver lettwin who gave
evidence to my lady that there would be
a benefit in his view of the UK
government having a senior cabinet level
Minister solely devoted full time to a
resilience portfolio do you think that
that is necessary within Scottish
government I think it's a reasonable
proposition and one that that is worthy
of consideration because I think we are
if I look back on my ministerial career
um I spent 16 years as a minister and I
dealt with quite a number of resilience
incidents across a whole range of
different responsibilities and sectors
so
and as I look at some of the factors
that are now affecting Society issues
around about climate for example
I I only think that resilience issues
are going to become ever more
significant and present and
look at some of the evidence that
Bolivia's heard in relation to the the
the scenarios that can be faced as the
world changes uh you know as population
Rises as climate change has its effect
there may well be a strong argument for
the proposition that so so Oliver let
one has put forward
I want to now ask you about a series of
bodies and committees that were set up
either just before or during your time
in office and I want to begin with the
cabinet subcommittee on Scottish
government resilience also known as CSC
ore I think
um now the role of this particular
committee was to give ministerial
oversights to strategic policy and
guidance in the context of resilience in
Scotland is that right that's great yes
and this committee met in preparation
for emergency response and in order to
keep abreast of matters related to
promoting and improving civil protection
and also preparing for special
contingencies such as pandemic influenza
it was set up some considerable time ago
and indeed the last recorded meeting of
it took place on the 14th of April of
2010. now I want to go to those meeting
notes please which are at 102 935 thank
you and we can see the date there and
present are yourself and also Nicholas
sturgeon and if we scroll down please we
can also see others present some of
whose names have been redacted
let's go please to page seven and I'd
like to look at paragraphs 11 and 12.
now of course if we remind ourselves
that 2010 was just after we had suffered
the swine flu outbreak we can see it
paragraph 11 somebody present introduced
a paper which analyzed the implications
of the lessons identified from the
recent emergencies for the Scottish
government's role in coordinating
National Emergency responses
he said that the requirements for score
to be activated had greatly increased
over the last three years which included
activation for the fuel shortages in
2008 the flu pandemic that's the swine
flu pandemic and an increasing number of
weather-related incidents Scottish
resilience would shortly undertake a
significant review of scores capacity
and its capability to support enhanced
National decision making in the light of
the lessons learned and this would
include options for improvements in
accommodation I.T training and Staffing
could we scroll down please
he said that the Lessons Learned would
also provide an opportunity to develop
score as a National Emergency
information analysis and decision-making
Hub which was in line with the shared
services agenda and National performance
framework it was planned to have
discussions with kosler akpos and the
Chief Fire Officers Association Scotland
on the option of co-locating mutual Aid
coordination centers for police fire and
local authorities with score such
coordination would enable organizations
to share resources and allow for a more
streamlined approach to the collection
and Analysis of information
thank you we don't need to read in any
further so this was a committee which as
of April 2010 and Not only was active
and had been activated because of the
the national issues that had Arisen fuel
shortages pandemic a swine flu and also
issues with climate change but it was
also very much looking forward to
providing a level of service in terms of
what was being anticipated
do you agree at that
as far as this meeting was concerned it
very much looked as if the committee was
going to be busy
yes and the the work that flowed from
that over a number of years I think
demonstrates exactly that point so why
why was this the last occasion upon
which this Mitty this committee met
essentially what the the work that was
all envisaged in the paragraphs that
have been read into the record was all
work that was then taken forward but not
with the
um necessity of the supervision of that
particular committee
um we essentially developed structures
which had
um which involved the creation of a
Scottish resilience partnership which in
a sense was living out the point that I
needed in one of my earlier answers
which was that resilience had to be
everybody's business so we needed to
have a range of different organizations
very much engaged in the preparation of
active resilience functions many of
which are listed in those paragraphs 11
and 12 that have been read
so that work was taken forward through
the Scottish resilience partnership and
there was direct ministerial involvement
in that I would have attended a number
of Scottish resilience partnership
meetings to provide the Strategic
ministerial Direction and and
oversee in the course of a range of
different other incidents because after
2010 we would have a number of other
resilience um incidents in which we were
actively involved and we would
essentially develop that working
practice I I understand your answer that
the work was taken forward by other
bodies but you will understand that the
UK government had an equivalent
committee called the NSC thrc or the
threats committee that didn't meet in
person between 2013 and 2017 and then it
didn't meet in person thereafter the
inquiry has heard that evidence already
do you think that there is value now in
this sort of committee being reconvened
and regularly meeting in order to ensure
that these matters are kept very much
within the Forefront of ministers Minds
my first response is to see that I I do
genuinely feel that these issues are
very much at the Forefront of Minister's
Minds I I I I can say to
um Malaysian inquiry these issues have
kept me awake at night for many many
years on different questions whether
it's about winter weather incidents or
about the pandemic flu so there are very
much issues that have been under
um active management and handling by
ministers with active engagement on a
proactive basis to identify threats and
risks because that's what led to the
production of the Scottish risk
assessment for the first time in 2018
which was to try to calibrate the risks
that we might face and but there may
well be the need for a particular Forum
to look
um periodically formally
in a recorded fashion a to take stock
about where preparations happen to be I
think one of the reasons why
we felt this committee didn't need to
meet was that if I go back to the
attendance list of that meeting that you
cited from 2010 that was all members of
the cabinet were present there apart
from the reinforest minister so we had
cabinet meeting on a weekly basis which
allowed us to conduct some of these
issues as well all right thank you
um I next want to ask you about the
Scottish resilience partnership which
you've just mentioned the first issue is
to make sure that I'm addressing it by
its correct title because when I
suggested yesterday to Jillian Russell
who set up the committee that it was
called the Scottish resilience
partnership she corrected me and said it
was called the Strategic resilience
partnership which is it please the the
risk of contradicting a civil servant
and it is in my view the Scottish
resilience partnership but it has a
strategic remix of that perhaps to build
the bridge that's where the uh the
difficulty arose
um but any event that this was set up
during your time in office
but it was restricted wasn't it to
category one responders do you think
that that was in in hindsight perhaps
too narrow a remit do you think it
should have been extended to to other
bodies um Beyond category one responders
I I I I don't think so but but I
wouldn't really say to look at this
question I think it's important to to
look at who those category one
responders are so around the table of
the Scottish resilience partnership
would be the leadership of Scotland's 32
local authorities the chief Constable of
police Scotland the Chief Fire officer
of the fan rescue service the chief
executive of the Scottish environment
Protection Agency
um the chief is
um and the there will be others that I
haven't managed to remember off the top
of my head so they would be representing
a very broad cross-section of those who
would have to deliver the resilience
response and crucially
would have to make sure that appropriate
preparations were being undertaken at a
more local level whether that was across
the three
three regional resilience partnership
areas in Scotland or the 32 local
resilience Partnerships representing
each of the local Authority areas
so that body had to consider what my
future threats be and they had to make
sure that we were developing the
processes and the infrastructure that
would enable us to handle any
circumstances should an issue arise
does involved in or in attendance at
these meetings quite frequently
um I I certainly remember being
personally at a number of these
resilience partnership meetings
um and that was to essentially prove
that attendance was to provide
the direction of ministerial thinking so
we would be considered I can remember
contributing to those discussions around
a range of issues
some of which would be about
um pandemic flu some would be about
winter weather some would be about cyber
security for example which would be you
know a number of the they've been alive
in topical issues that we'd be
discussing
in your witness statement to the inquiry
you say paragraph nine in the period
running up to January 2020 the
preparations for a pandemic were taken
forward in Scotland as a combination of
participation in the four nations
activity across the UK and specific
applications of this approach to the
distinctive Health and Social care
Arrangements that reflected the devolved
governance Arrangements
and that the approach of the Scottish
government would be best summed up as a
pragmatic way of cooperating on a four
nations basis
how do you say Mr Swinney that there was
pragmatic cooperation between Scotland
and the United Kingdom government in
terms of preparation
I think there would be examples of that
would be a collaboration around
um some of the expert advice that would
be available so for example and there
will be representatives from Scotland
that would take part in organizations
such as Sage for example a nerve type
and we would gather and expert
information and advice to inform our own
thinking within Scotland so I would cite
that as an example of where we weren't
trying to replicate what would be
a very good and strong source of
um scientific advice and professional
advice to government
there would be cooperation around
um some aspects of procurement and in
relation to
mppe I think are I recall so I I and
then there would be other Dialogue on a
four Nation basis where it that there
really was no particular value in US
um undertaking a different and
distinctive uh process all right well
we're going to come on and look at some
of those but whatever the political
point that could be made about the the
devolved administrations and their
their connection and the strength of
their connection to the United Kingdom
government the truth is that pandemic
planning was and ought to have been UK
wide as an effort shouldn't it with each
Nation performing a role in a collective
Endeavor to prepare for a pandemic I
would say that yes
so
I don't want to to dwell upon it because
the the inquiry has heard evidence from
several witnesses now about this but I'm
sure you will accept Mr Swinney that the
UK influencer preparedness strategy of
2011 should have been updated prior to
covert hitting but wasn't updated
I've obviously heard that David and
she's and and were you aware at the time
when you were in office
there were plans afoot to update it but
those plans in fact never came to
fruition
I wouldn't say I was specifically aware
of that particular point you know
um you
you know there's a a pandemic flew
preparedness board was set up yes
following the exercise cygnus
recommendations and one of the aspects
of of work for that board was to update
the strategy that work was eventually
paused because of
um preparations for a No Deal EU exit
is it a source of regret
for you Mr Swinney that on your watch
that preparedness strategy was not
updated obviously I I would
um in all circumstances prefer to be
able to achieve all of the the
commitments that were given to um update
material and to prepare accordingly I
think there's a strong evidence of
pandemic preparations in the strategies
that were taken forward and in the work
that was undertaken particularly within
um the uh the the the the health Team
within the Scottish government that led
on on pandemic preparation for that to
be the case but there's obviously
aspects of work which have suffered as a
consequence of
what are the in my experience the
inevitable congestion of multiple
priorities that can often exist and as
the inquiry will have heard and the
preparations for a new deal brexit where
a very real threat which had to be
addressed and as a consequence some
aspects of the work that was necessary
to be undertaken for other areas of
activity was not able to be completed
can I suggest in addition to that though
there appears to have been a
sluggishness within the Scottish
government to implement aspects of not
only and the exercise cygnus
recommendations but also those that had
come from exercise Silver Swan in 2016
and exercise Irish Iris in 2018 because
yesterday
um during the evidence of Gillian
Russell we looked at some of the minutes
from the pandemic flu preparedness board
from June of 2019.
and some of the comments within those
minutes expressed a surprise at how slow
matters were progressing
and in addition to that we've heard this
morning from Nicholas sturgeon that so
far as guidance for Health and Social
care is concerned there was a
recommendation for that to be updated as
far back as the exercise Silver Swan
report in 2016. and she has confirmed to
the inquiry this morning that when she
left office in March of this year that
had still not been implemented so that
is guidance and recommendations from
several years ago
do you agree that that demonstrates
an alarming sluggishness for the
implementation of what are important
recommendations
I I think that there is
significant guidance available in
relation to the
preparation for and the handling of a
pandemic and that guidance
um would be shared with
um with health boards who would carry
the responsibility for many of the
actions that would be envisaged in such
plan
the question
so there would be an element of guidance
that would be available there was
perhaps a well there is a requirement
from the commitments given here for that
to be strengthened and advanced so it
wasn't there was no guidance available
it's that perhaps updates were not
provided in a Timmy's period for that
seven years
yes no update within seven years to that
guidance but there would be other work
that would be undertaken through the
successive exercises between silver
sworn cygnus and Iris which would be
helping the learning within different
organizations as those
um exercises took their course and as
professionals saw the sequence of events
that were being under the the that were
unfolding so there was a a source of
information to assist in the
strengthening of guidance but the final
material was available for consultation
around about the time when the covert
pandemic struck all right it
it doesn't give the impression that that
those recommendations
were were being speedily addressed does
it there's a lot of work being
undertaken but I think what I would have
to concede is that there are multiple
priorities that
are difficult to wrestle with within
government and and I I I I don't want to
to labor the point but other events come
along that unfortunately slow things up
and nodial brexit is one example there
would be other incidents that would
happen there would be other events that
would happen in the sequence events that
perhaps would mean that at all the
timetables we wanted to complete were
not able to be completed as we would
wish
from your perspective Mr Sweeney what
was the impetus and purpose behind a
Scottish risk assessment being
implemented
I would see its purpose was to to take
the the learning that we had from the
uk-wide risk assessment and to ensure
that the it was tailored in any way that
was appropriate for it to be tailored to
the specific circumstances within
Scotland so that would be more relevant
on some of the challenges we would face
in relation to
um winter weather for example which
would be perhaps a more acute challenge
for us than other parts of the United
Kingdom and but its purpose and its
objective was to be complementary to the
United Kingdom National risk assessment
right can we put up please the Scottish
risk assessment for 2018 it's at one
zero two nine four zero thank you and if
we look to page three
thank you
we can see your smiling face there Mr
Swinney
together with if we look on the right
hand column
your personal feelings about the
implementation of this assessment I feel
very strongly that resilience is
everyone's business our combined efforts
to protect our society are the test of
our resilience the ongoing Safety and
Security of our communities is the
measure of our success building a shared
understanding of the risks we face in
Scotland is vital if we are to do this
successfully
does does that accurately depict how you
felt at the time that this was
implemented yes it does thank you
um I don't want to Again cover evidence
that the inquiry has already heard but
you will I think agree Mr Swinney that
so far as risk assessments are concerned
there is a risk assessment for pandemic
influenza and there are risk assessments
for high consequence infectious diseases
but nothing in between and the evidence
that the inquiry has heard is that
consideration should be given to
multiple scenarios or a spectrum of
risks and that and that going forwards
the risk assessments both nationally and
also
within the devolved administrations
should concentrate on on a much wider
variety of what those risks should be
I think that's a reasonable Point
um I think the
in the compilation of the Scottish
assessment and an effort was put in to
try to ensure that we addressed the
range of circumstances that we might
face and
um if my memory says me right I think in
this risk assessment we identified and
prioritize 10 within that report and but
obviously within that there are a
multiplicity of different scenarios on
each and every one of those
um themes so to go back to to this risk
assessment and we would identify I think
we probably identified
um pandemic flu and winter weather as
the two highest and most likely risks
with the greatest degree of impact
within those
there would be countless scenarios that
might well be considered and I think
part of the challenge in all of this
work
is to be able to
satisfactory identify just how many
scenarios it might be possible to
consider and then further to prepare for
them because they will require a very
different response and of course all of
that
stands to be very resource intensive in
the process yes yes or to have a plan
that is flexible enough to to deal with
different levels of or types of
transmission and incubation periods and
that sort of thing
the inquiry has also heard that there is
a doctrinal issue with the way in which
the reasonable worst case scenario is
unmitigated and encourages those
planning for risks to plan for the
consequences rather than for preventing
them do you agree with that
I think the the the the the the
doctrinal approach in resilience I think
is
is certainly focused on trying to
um mitigate the the impact and to secure
recovery as speedily as possible but I
don't think that
does Justice to The Wider
um perspective within government which
at least certainly in the Scottish
government leads have very heavy
emphasis on prevention so we you know in
so many aspects of
um Scott's government policy there is an
emphasis on early intervention and
prevention to avoid
um damaging circumstances emerging
whether that's on policy questions such
as
um child poverty or early learning in in
interventions and
but it it has an application to
um some of the resilience questions as
well
well I'd just like to
to explore
in a little more detail could we put up
87205 please this is uh
a minute from the meeting of the
pandemic diseases capabilities board in
April of 2022 so it's after the pandemic
but I'd like to just look at the
analysis here of preparation in order to
better inform us of how
we really should be considering
preparing for any future pandemic and
can we go to page four please and look
at paragraph 16.
thank you
further in line with the National
Security risk assessment methodology
revised pandemic reasonable worst case
scenario models represent unmitigated
scenarios and so do not include a full
risk assessment for the use of npis
non-pharmaceutical interventions
given that the imposition of lockdown in
part accounted for a 25 drop in GDP
between February and April of 2020 the
largest drop on record and numerous
secondary and tertiary impacts on all
sectors this represents a significant
Gap in the UK's assessment of pandemic
risk noting that even without government
intervention we would anticipate
spontaneous Behavior change and
subsequent economic damage what is more
the secondary and tertiary aspects of
these measures will have been unevenly
spread throughout Society highlighting
and in areas exacerbating pre-existing
inequalities
we can go to page five please and then
look at recommendation 2.1
this recommendation is that all
departments are to use
disappeared
and there is recommendation 2.1 please
on page five I think it's at the top
there we are thank you all departments
to use the outputs of recommendation to
to produce a supplementary risk
assessment to the nsra that assesses the
impact of public behavioral changes on
their sectors
the outputs of this work should be
reviewed by ministers with a view to
determining which behavioral changes
fall within an agreed response ambition
that will provide clear planning
assumptions to enhance cross-government
preparedness arrangements for future NPI
deployment and then if we can go down to
read through paragraphs 18 to 20 please
the unprecedented use of npis and
significant changes in public Behavior
seen during the covid-19 pandemic
required the provision of far greater
economic support than pre-covered
planning assumptions suggested
the planning assumptions in the 2011 UK
influenza pandemic preparedness strategy
focused on the economic impacts of
sickness substances as a result the
strategy did not include many of the
significant economic impacts we have
seen during this pandemic such as the
dramatic drops in economic activity
significant shifts and reductions in
consumer spending and disruption to
Global Supply change
the obr's fiscal risks report from July
2021 suggests the UK's real GDP declined
by an unprecedented unprecedented 9.8
percent in 2020 and as of September 2021
the no Nao estimated the lifetime cost
of government spending on covid-19 will
reach 370 billion clearly then in line
with with recommendation 2.1 our
economic risk assessment for pandemics
must be updated to include a broader
range of impacts including the
significant potential impacts of mpis
and behavioral changes on different
sectors of the economy
So Not only was much of the planning and
preparedness concerned with preparing
for the reasonable worst case scenario
not preventing it from arising but it
would appear that
planning was never really designed to
deal with the Fallout of any of the
countermeasures that might be taken to
prevent or cope with the reasonable
worst case scenario do you agree
I I think it's
difficult to and this goes to the heart
of
um so much of the assessment work that's
got to be undertaken here to
um identify what might well be the range
of impacts that have to be wrestled with
in in any particular scenario and then
of course the most scenarios that we
consider
the broader the range of variables that
there will be and but I think what the
material that has been read I think
fairly highlights is the very
significant wider impact of a the
pandemic and its effect on our society
and you know as I we we will come on to
this in other modules of the inquiries
at work but
and after we took the steps to you know
the most alleged steps in March 2020 in
relation to
um to lockdown
and eyelid
a lot of work within government
which was about trying to essentially
reconcile much of this and this
information as to how we then
worked our way back out of that and it
became known as the four harms framework
where we looked at the direct covert
harm the indirect covert harm the
economic and the social harm that was
being caused and how we evaluated what
was the right amount of risk to to
wrestle with I suppose in terms of
trying to get out of a situation of
lockdown so in a sense
I offer that information to try to
illustrate that the dilemmas that are
involved very much in this material or
dilemmas that we were wrestling with but
I but I would concede that we were
wrestling with them after lockdown had
yes not before but going forward what
we've just read into to the record
should become part of pandemic planning
shouldn't it yeah I would say it needs
to yes Mr Swinney I'm afraid I'm not
going to finish your evidence before the
break which we have to take in a couple
of minutes but before we do break I'd
just like to ask you one more question
because you were the cabinet secretary
for finance and sustainable growth for
nine years
um what are your views on the fact that
as a result of what we've just discussed
there was no real Financial pandemic
planning put in place for support or
countermeasures
uh if I answer that in relation to the
context I was dealing in which is within
the Scottish government
um I suspect
the equation Mr Blackwell might be
getting towards what why didn't you have
a Josef to deal with these circumstances
and as I think a number of favorites
um witness statements have provided this
detail to the inquiry
that was not within my gift to create
the financial Arrangements of devolution
essentially required the Scottish
government to balance its Budget on an
annual basis and any resources that are
carried forward are only carried forward
on a very limited basis from One
Financial year to another so we are
specifically by the financial the
Scottish government is specifically
prevented from building up a reserve
that it can deploy for eventualities of
this type that's a commentary on the
existing Financial Arrangements that
exist
um within the Scottish
um within the Scottish parliament of
what I would
um acknowledge and I've acknowledged
this publicly in many occasions
the scale of the economic intervention
made by the United Kingdom government
um in and around about March 2020 and
thereafter
was
um
very welcome from my perspective and it
saved
you know many people's livelihoods from
you know great Jeopardy and but it is an
illustration of the scale of the
financial challenge that comes with a
disruptive pandemic of this nature all
right thank you very much my ladies
that's a convenient moment thank you
very much sorry we can't complete you
this morning Mr sweetie I shall return
of course to two please
all rise
foreign
it's Blackwell thank you my lady Mr
Sweeney the first topic I want to ask
you about this afternoon is
intergovernmental relations which is
something that was touched upon by Miss
sturgeon in her evidence this morning
and for you to confirm that in relation
to the Civil contingencies Act of 2004
there was a Concord act between the
United Kingdom government and Scottish
ministers that was published in February
of 2021 which was an agreed framework
for cooperation between Scottish
ministers and the UK government
not a legally binding agreement but with
an expectation that each party would
abide by it wherever practicable is that
right
exists yes but I think the date is much
earlier than 2021 did I say to it I
meant 2011. I'm so sorry yeah yeah I'm
glad you picked me up yes yes yes I
think in me you'd be even earlier than
that right February of 2011 is the date
that I have here but yeah in any event
it came into
it it came into Force I used that word
Loosely because of course there was no
legal finding nature
um attached to it but an expectation
that the Scottish ministers in the UK
government would abide by it and
if if indeed from from um before if you
think that the uh the agreement might
have um might have extended back beyond
that date
um Scottish ministers agreed that
certainly the spirit of the Civil
contingencies act would be followed and
from that time uh category 1 and
category two responders were identified
as um indeed happened in England yeah so
the the recent part has just been a bit
excited about the time skill is that I I
do have a I Concord that which was
um predates our government coming to
office in 2007 so it must have followed
I think
sometimes soon after the passage of the
Civil contingencies act and in 2004. so
those arrangements were off were already
in place we're already in place and
um the for example
um envisaged the designation of
invisible they require the designation
of an individual within the Scottish
government to be i i i i
official level
key resilience person if I could use
that terminology and that was always
followed through so just just so that I
was clear about that thank you very much
and in 2013 in fact there was a
memorandum of understanding and
supplementary agreement between the
United Kingdom government and all of the
devolved nations with the intention of
the Devolution settlements and during
having enduring qualities of good
communication Etc wasn't there so so
there were these these agreements in
place from from I'm going to suggest
soon after Devolution happened which
which always attempted to propel along a
good-natured agreement and good
communication between the Nations that's
good yes right
but we know that
covid and commissioned by the four heads
of government there was a review of
intergovernmental relations and we know
that because a report was produced dated
January of 2022 and I think that was
referred to during this morning's
session
Michael Gove who will be coming to this
inquiry to give evidence
um at a later date who is currently
Secretary of State for D luck and
Minister for intergovernmental relations
has told the inquiry in his written
statement that at the time of the
pandemic it was apparent that the
broader matter of intergovernmental
relations was not clearly agreed and
there were difficulties encountered in
relation to communication but also
matters of substance
does the fact that the four heads of
state commissioned the review of
intergovernmental relations
suggest that Michael Gove might be right
that
the Practical difficulties that were
encountered when covid hit in terms of
communication and substance
indicated that that further work needs
to be done in terms of the way in which
the Nations work together in an
emergency
I I wouldn't see that
um the working Arrangements in an
emergency were particularly poor and I
think there was generally a pretty good
amount of cooperation when we were
operating in an emergency and in that
respect I'm going up a way back to my
period since 2007. we are generally when
there was a difficulty and and we were
perhaps involved in a Cobra call which
is the UK emergency call and there would
be you know a lot of
um reasonable practice practical
engagement in an emergency context
but
the reason why that
um process had to be undertaken to form
an agreement about how we were all going
to operate was that generally
relationships between the
administrations were pretty poor by that
point
in the aftermath of brexit because
obviously
constituent parts of the United Kingdom
and we were in Scotland we were not
happy with brexit at all or not happy
with the and all of a sudden to spend a
lot of time in the nodio brexit as the
inquiry heard this morning
from Nico sturgeon
um but generally relations are pretty
poor all right and and therefore there
was a you know a necessity to try to
formulate some working basis upon which
intergovernmental relationships could be
improved so moving forwards in terms of
preparing for future pandemics or future
civil emergencies any
any level of clarity as to how
Communications and matters of substance
should be taken forward between the four
nations would be welcomed yes thank you
just in case an Eagle Eye commentator
spots I think you by Stephen tongue said
four heads of state I'm so sorry I
didn't mean to say that the heads of
government okay
thank you
um
I want to move on now to ask you about
the level of Engagement Community
engagement between the Scottish
government
and local government and also the
Scottish leaders forum and you tell us
in your witness statement that one of
the Hallmarks of the operating approach
of Scottish government during the period
that this module is interested in was to
engage widely with other public
authorities public bodies business and
third sector organizations to create a
sense of common purpose in your endeavor
and you tell us that that was achieved
through forums such as the Scottish
leaders Forum which brings together
senior public sector leaders from across
Scotland
has regular dialogue with major business
representative organizations and
interaction with a representative range
of third sector organizations
tell us how important the Scottish
leaders forum and the interaction
between government and those sectors is
very important
um on all aspects of government policy I
think if I I'm not out of government one
of my big Reflections is that when the
big problems of government is that
um government often operates within
individual compartments and the
necessity of
across
responsibility working to try to sort
common problems you know the problem of
of child poverty or if climate change
will not be solved in one neat little
compartment and government it will
involve a whole range of different
organizations
as will any issue in relation to
resilience will invariably require a
range of different organizations to be
part of it so what
um the government to which I was apart
tried to Foster was a climate of
collaboration cooperation across
different public and private sector
boundaries third sector boundaries so
Scottish leaders Forum would bring
together
um basically
the key public sector and such sector
private sector leaders around the
country
to try to formulate common purpose and a
common
direction of travel in solving problems
that um we're all interested in solving
but might have slightly different
perspectives about who could do what in
the process right in terms of
um
emergency preparedness and pandemic
planning what level of Engagement was
there between the Scottish government
and the voluntary sector
and there would be
dialogue through
um you know the the routine
conversations we would have with the
thought sector about you know how they
could perform
um a role within the delivery of policy
so if I think back to
um periods where
um you know I had responsibility if I
started set to relationships 2007 to
roll over 2012. you know we'd be
regularly involved in the third sector
and the formulation of strategy what
role they could perform how they could
be involved when they got to the stage
of and dealing with the pandemic thought
sector organizations would be operating
very closely with local resilience
Partnerships because you know we would
encourage we actually
not just in colors but we funded
um what were called third sector
interfaces at local level in the 32
local authorities in Scotland so I
thought sector had a an ability to
influence
the direction of policy and Service
delivery at local level
the inquiry has received a statement
from Helen fiskin representing an
organization called inclusion Scotland
it's an independent non-party political
representative organization of disabled
people across Scotland with a network of
over 50 DPO members and partner
organizations as well as individual
members and I want to give you the
opportunity Mr Swinney to to respond to
what she tells us in her statement
prior to January 2020 we were not
invited to engage with government UK
Scottish or local regarding the extent
to which inequalities and
vulnerabilities should be factored into
emergency preparedness and pandemic
planning we have routinely highlighted
the obligation on the UK and Scottish
governments to involve disabled people
in the development of Law and policy
failure to do this adequately means that
inequalities faced by disabled people
were not sufficiently factored into
emergency preparedness and pandemic
planning what does it say Mr Swinney
about the partnership approach that such
a significant organization representing
such an important and vulnerable
constituency in society were not subject
to engagement I I think I'm I'm I've
read Heather friskins and witness
statement and obviously I'm troubled by
its contents because that's the last
impression of feeling I would want a
person like Heather Fisk in the
organization that she represents to have
and I think the government the Scottish
government has gone to a lot of lenses I
just have recounted through the
the arrangements that we put in place to
make sure the third sector have got a
voice throughout the formulation of
policy whether that's around the design
of
um Scottish government policy or
legislation that's brought forward and
you know there's extensive consultation
with um
a thought sector organizations about
um
the formulation of policy within the
Scottish government so I I'm very
troubled that that is the impression
that Heather fiskin has about the extent
to which
um or the organization she represents
has been involved it's not just an
impression is it it's she sets out quite
clearly that having offered her the
assistance of that organization and and
acknowledging the importance of an
organization like that being involved in
pandemic planning and her pleas were
ignored
the fact that that's the case and
um I think that you know that that can
should be rectified by the Scottish
government thank you
I want to return now to again to
something that was covered in evidence
this morning and following on from your
comments that certainly at some point
during the um covert outbreak relations
between the the Scottish government and
the United Kingdom government were not
perhaps as cordial as they should have
been
um it's the UK resilience forum and the
presence or absence of Scottish
government at these meetings and given
that there was a level of
um or a lack of clarity following Miss
sturgeon's evidence about whether or not
the Scottish government were present at
some of the meetings I think it's
important for us to look very briefly at
the minutes so can we look at the
minutes of the first meeting please
which are at 198 919 this is the meeting
on the 14th of July of 2021 chaired by
paymaster General Penny mordant and if
we can scroll down please
I don't think sturgeon was questioning
that the minutes existed no no I think
she was questioning the accuracy yes the
minutes or indeed whether or not um the
government were present so we can see um
representatives from the following
organizations who are in attendance
Scottish government are the first in the
list thank you if we can now look to the
second meeting which is at
198-920 this is a meeting that took
place on the 3rd of May of 2022 chaired
by Minister for the cabinet office
Michael Ellis and if we can scroll down
please to those present and absent
thank you if we can scroll up the page
please thank you we can see invited
organizations unable to attend Scottish
government and then finally
198-921 which is the third meeting
taking place on the 2nd of February of
2023 chaired by Oliver Dowden
and if we can look at those in
attendance and those absent please
invited organizations unable to attend
at the bottom of the page
we can see fourth bullet-down Scottish
government so it it rather looks as if
the minutes suggest that the Scottish
government were not present in in
meetings two and three my question to
you is this
do you think that they're absence from
these meetings was a reflection on the
poor quality of relations between the
Nations
I wonder if I might just see on that the
minute that last minute I wonder if I
could just see a slightly higher updates
just the one that's on the screen now
yeah please could you see that it's um
um I just wanted to check it says
meeting helden
sorry it's if we can go to the next page
please
forgive me for not at all
um
because it's material to the answer yes
to give
um it says meeting Health in person on
my video conference okay yeah and thank
you and so no I don't think it's about
the um the nature of relations in the
short time I've had to explore this and
as I say I'm no longer a member of
government so it takes me slightly
longer to get answers to things these
days the only on the first meeting
Scottish government was present
on the second meeting and the Scottish
government had planned to be present by
from what I've been advised and the
video link was not working and
unfortunately there were people with
people ready to be involved but could
not participate because of technical
issues
and on the third meeting and what I've
been advised and and that's why I wanted
to see this wording was that it was an
in-person meeting in London at that
minute contradicts what I've been told
and
um this was a period where we were
wrestling with winter weather challenges
and our staff numbers were under
pressure I'm also not certain that these
um were invitations extended to
ministers to participate
um so I would need to check whether that
was a minister information but
around this
time
certainly I learned about this period
I discussed collaboration on this
question with Michael Ellis who was
I think at the time a minister for the
cabinet office yes he was
and basically we had an in principle
conversation about the necessity for
cooperation so to go back to the the
question you picked him in the splatable
did I think this was in it that the
absence of the Scottish government was
in any way an indication of poor
relations on that point no unreservedly
not I think it was perhaps Logistics and
issues that got in the way but I I will
make sure there is a definitive answer
given to the inquiry to explain that
point thank you very much the final
matter I want to ask you about is the
national performance framework and we
can see this at one zero two nine one
seven
this was established
I think during your time in office
and
it demonstrates that organizations in
Scotland were working together doesn't
it to
achieve Collective aspirations for for
all members of society encouraging them
to do so yes
it's one zero two nine one seven please
right now this this
is a a pictorial representation of the
framework isn't it can you explain to us
how it works please Mr Sweeney
essentially what
um at the core of it in the center are
um
an explanation of the purpose of
Scottish public policy and the values
that she'd underpin that and in the
circular area in the center and then
around the boat at our um a series of um
National outcomes that we work with
others in Scotland and whether they're
in the local Authority Partners or set
the organizations the private sector to
agree to try to achieve those outcomes
so they are aspirational about the a the
type of country we're trying to create
the reason that I wanted to highlight it
during the course of your evidence was
that the inquiry has heard from samark
walport who spoke of the need regardless
of of what approach government takes to
Future funding of national resilience we
perhaps should consider having a
national resilience assessment across
all areas of society in order to ensure
that the best level of resilience is is
achieved do you think that that
principle could work together with the
um the the the national uh performance
framework that we see is is currently
enforced in Scotland I I think that
would be beneficial and I think there is
a a constant challenge that we've got to
be aware of on resilience issues about
how the world is changing
that I can perhaps give a an
illustration of that and we had a very
severe and acute storm in the northeast
of Scotland storm Irwin there was a very
extensive amount of damage particularly
to power cables
and what of course we discovered very
very quickly is that without post
supplies
people's dependence on mobile technology
Broadband for which
vast amounts of life now hinge stops
and it's all very well seeing you know
we'll get the power back on tomorrow but
if the power can't go on for seven days
which in Stone Mountain was the case
that is an acute challenge to people so
the resilience effort is you know
incredible understand I'm not much of an
electrical engineer
um you need the proper people who know
what they're doing to do that
necessity for whole system approaches to
resilience threats whatever they happen
to be which so Mark is suggesting is I
think a very welcome suggestion
thank you very much my lady that
concludes my questions for Mr Swinney
you have provisionally granted
permission for Scottish covet bereaved
to ask two discrete questions may they
do that now please Mitchell
obliged
I'm obliged and in fact
um one of the questions has already been
dealt with in full uh before with Miss
sturgeon so I only need to take you to
one question now
um I'd like Mr Swinney for your comment
on evidence given to this inquiry by Dr
Jim mcmenaman he was a consultant
epidemiologist and health protection
Scotland and as you all know that's the
lead body protecting the Scottish public
from infectious diseases at the time
the pandemic planning was taking place
and also at the time just before the
pandemic
um I'm not going to ask the inquiry to
physically go to the statement but just
for the record it's his statement the
inquiry at number zero zero zero one
eight three four one zero and in that
statement to the inquiry a paragraph 146
he explains that Staffing numbers
reduced at um Health protection Scotland
between 2005 and 2020. now he indicated
that this was due to a number of factors
but he specifically highlighted that one
of the factors was the requirement
placed on all NHS boards by the Scottish
government to meet what he describes as
cash release releasing efficiency
savings
and as a result of that of course
clearly Staffing numbers were affected
further he explains at paragraph 145
that the newly formed Public Health
Scotland so the body that was taking
over
um from the other one
uh the opening budget for that and
Staffing levels were not sufficient for
public health Scotland to deliver the
health protection and response required
by the pandemic
from your position having in your own
words this morning the responsibility to
make Scotland in a stronger position as
it could be for any eventuality we had
to face do you accept the evidence of Dr
Jim mcmenaman that amongst other factors
the Scottish government requiring a
requirement to make cash savings in the
previous body
the newly formed Public Health Scotland
didn't have the budget or Staffing
levels to provide Health protection for
Scotland pre-pandemic
my view is that public health Scotland
provided the Scottish government
a local Authority partners and I made
reference to this in my own witness
statement
and with
um a huge amount of
immensely reliable information and
trusted information to enable us to form
our decisions so part of the benefit of
the reform which was undertaken to
establish
um Public Health Scotland was it was a
body jointly
um owned if I could use that terminology
between the government and local
authorities so there was and often
um book authorities might dispute the
evidence base that government has taken
its decisions based on on this example
there was none of that because we
jointly owned the body of Public Health
Scotland and there was wide confidence
quality of the material and information
that came from public health Scotland
so in that respect I I want to put that
on the record about the strength of that
information that was available from
which decision name Kim
and where I would accept is that
um there were Financial
um pressures the financial pressures
through every aspect of the public
sector in Scotland and and we've had a
prolonged period of
um of austerity which has required us to
make and to live within very challenging
for school a very challenging fiscal
environment in the Scottish government
having said that
the health budget which would funded
Public Health Scotland would have been
the budget that grew the most
compared to any other aspect of the
public of public budgets so
yes there would be efficiency savings
required they were required of everybody
but in that context the health budget
was growing
to a greater extent than any other part
of the public budgets for which the
Scottish government has responsibility
so what and what that answer is designed
to do is to is to acknowledge the
strength of Public Health scope and but
also to accept the in a challenging
fiscal environment and we have to ask
organizations to perform strongly to uh
to live within the financial resources
we have available to us
so despite the fact that Health Scott
um would have had the budget That Grew
most compared to other aspects of public
life it still wasn't in terms of budget
or in terms of Staffing prepared for the
pandemic well I I I I I certainly from
my experience of Public Health sculpted
I thought Public Health Scotland
contributed formidably to the handling
of the pandemic and at no stage did I
feel
um that we did not have the necessary
information or interventions available
to us from what particular doctor McMann
and his colleagues at that time so from
my perspective I felt they were able to
make that contribution but I do
acknowledge that um the the burden of
um austerity and the requirement for
efficiency savings has been acute for
many organizations
thank you melody that concludes thank
you very much Miss Mitchell
thank you very much indeed Mr Sweeney
thank you for your help thank you
[Applause]
my lady the Final witness of the day and
indeed of this week is Catherine Francis
could you take the oath or a firm please
I do solemnly sincerely and truly
declare and affirm I shall give that the
evidence I shall give shall be the truth
shall be the truth the whole truth the
whole truth
laughs
please sit down
is your name Catherine Francis it is
Miss Francis thank you for coming to
give evidence today and thank you for
the assistance that you've given so far
and you've provided a witness statement
which we'll look at on the screen in a
moment before we confirm that this is
your witness statement I notice that
you're quite softly spoken that's not a
criticism but please keep your voice up
and speak into the microphones so that
the stenographer can hear you for the
transcript if you need a break during
the course of your evidence just ask and
we will do that
so can you confirm please miss Francis
that this is your witness statement I
can thank you and we don't need to go
there but can you also confirm that at
the end you have signed it as being true
to the best of your knowledge and belief
I
thank you we can take that down please
you are the director general for local
government resilience and communities a
post which you have held since April of
2019 that's correct I think that you
joined the Civil Service in 2001 and
prior to joining this department you
were director of Public Services in Her
Majesty's treasury that's correct thank
you now a warning my lady we are about
to enter a realm of Shifting acronyms
and names so I'm going to try and deal
with all at once so that we we can then
move on
um
Miss Francis I I need your assistance in
relation to uh how the government is
formed and its previous iterations
please
the department of leveling up housing
and communities referred to as D luck
which I'm going to use uh during the
course of your evidence has operated in
various forms and under various names
over its lifetime hasn't it
it was created in 2006 to replace the
office of the Deputy Prime Minister
which had taken on the local government
and regions portfolio from the
Department for transport local
government and the regions in 2002.
when it was first formed the department
was called the department for
communities and local government dclg
but then in January of 2018 it became
the ministry of housing communities and
local government
mhclg and then in September of 2021 it
became D luck have I got that right you
have got them
um
you are responsible in your role for
what we know as red which is the
resilience and emergencies division
although it is now known as the
resilience and Recovery directorate is
that right that is correct I'm going to
refer to it as red during the course of
your evidence and
just pausing that why has that
particular name changed
um it's changed for
reasons firstly because this is part of
our organization which works on on
resilience planning and response and we
wanted uh to recognize that we were
thinking in a holistic way about how you
recover from emergencies as well as how
you just immediately respond so the name
has been changed for that purpose it's
also been changed to reflect I think
over time changes in the resourcing of
that team and set of teams it is now run
by a director who has responsibility uh
solely for that function and previously
it's been in slightly different
Arrangements over the years all right
thank you
the department is a ministerial
Department with oversight for local
government and elections homelessness
housing and Home Ownership planning
building safety and leveling up on the
union since 2021
but the inquiry is in interested in its
in its oversight in terms of local
government uh because it oversees the
local government sector and is
responsible for the stewardship and
oversight of local authorities in
England which includes ensuring that the
Frameworks for accountability and
finance of local government are robust
and that local authorities operate in
accordance with what's described as a
best value regime
that is a correct description of our
role nationally in relation to local
government I think it's important for
the inquiry to understand and that
because local government does so many
different things
in England the way that this is
organized is that the lead government
department for a particular service area
would take National oversight and
accountability for that so to give you
an example
the department for Health and Social
care would be responsible at National
level for social care even though local
authorities are a major player in Social
care similarly the Department of
Education would be responsible for
children's services
um and we as a department would be
responsible for homelessness at a
national policy level right but you're
correct in your description that we do
the overarching framework and in terms
of resilience which is of particular
interest to this inquiry your department
shares joint competency for local
resilience with the cabinet's office I
think is that right
so the way to think about our
Department's role is in two different uh
chunks if you like the first is as any
other government Department we have lead
areas of responsibility and they are
exactly as you as that out housing
homelessness building safety and local
government overarching
um accountancy in stewardship for
um there is then a separate function
that sits within our department which is
the resilience and emergencies division
now we know red yes now red performs a
function which is not just for our own
Department red performs a function on
behalf of all of government Central and
local
I can set up that role for you now if
it's helpful please yeah
um so
this is all based in in legislation and
in the simple contingencies framework
and then the supporting guidance that
goes with this so at National level
civil contingencies are arranged in such
a way as you have the cabinet office
with overarching responsibility
and they have responsibility in terms of
policy known as Doctrine for local
emergencies planning too
as you have probably heard from other
people there's often a lead government
Department which takes forward a
particular risk and plans for that
locally speaking we have a situation
defined in legislation where category 1
responders hospitals local authorities
blue lights
um have a responsibility for planning
for emergencies and then responding
emergencies
they also have a responsibility to come
together in local resilience forums and
those forums are in place to enable
planning and response when it needs a
cross-agency response locally
the role of red in that wider system is
in a sense relatively simple it is the
connecting team between the national
level civil contingencies arrangements
and the local lrfs so there's 38 lrfs in
England will have red connecting
officers working with them and they will
work with them on planning and also in
response I hope that's clear it is thank
you very much
um local government is responsible for a
range of services for people and
businesses in defined areas and and I'd
like your assistance please now on on
how the local government levels work so
there are different types of local
authorities aren't there correct can you
tell us what they are please
um yes so there are a range of different
types
um there are some authorities uh
Metropolitan authorities and
universities
um integrated authorities that have uh
responsibility for a full range of
services
to give you an example that would
include social care children's services
those sorts of services it would include
libraries it would also include
responsibilities for refuse collection
things like that and planning
um in other parts of the country where
we don't have that unitary Authority
that integrates both tiers and that can
be split between a county which holds
some responsibilities and underneath it
some District councils right and they
have separated uh lines of
responsibilities that are set out very
clearly in all legislation
um for example districts would do
um refuse and that sort of service and
uh at the county level you might find
adult social care and children's
services so it's a differing types of
local authorities it is a patchwork
across the country
um well understood by practitioners but
it is not regular
and then in addition to that in some
parts of the country there are combined
authorities or may or combined
authorities they bring together the
authorities in the area and have certain
accountabilities that are set out in a
series largely of devolution deals and
then legislation that follows those
if it what
less directly response
response services that are affected
immediately in in a pandemic response
right but what's what's the
interrelation between the local
resilience forums and and local
authorities is there a direct
correlation between the area that a
local resilience Forum covers and under
local Authority or does some local
resilience forums cross boundaries
um thank you for asking that question so
in the legislation the 38 local
resilience forums are set out as being
along the same footprint as police
authorities
so that is what defines them
um
you can imagine that a local resilience
Forum will sometimes be responding to a
situation where the police maybe are the
lead agency so one can see why it's set
up two authorities uh
I would match your greater knowledge
I thought it was over 40. please forces
sorry forgive me for interrupting it may
have changed I don't know I'm afraid I
can't help you on that one
um you asked about the connection with
local authorities yes because they are
category one responders they are
required to engage with the local
resilience Forum
um of which they are a part as under the
Civil contingencies act exactly yes
um in practice what that can mean is
that you will have a local resilience
Forum that has several councils in it
that is perfectly standardized and you
may find that councils don't all
individually attend they can nominate
each other to attend on each other's
behalf
so the Department's role in preparedness
and risk management for civil
emergencies as we've established sits
within red and
um
you've explained how red really sits
between central government and local
government and and provides a conduit
for advice
does that extend to Assurance so so what
level of assurance does red have over
plans and Arrangements that are local
that might be held at a local level
um okay just to break this down so
firstly I think we do have civil
contingencies responsibilities as a
department outside red as any other yes
as any other department would but just
looking at Red
um its role is to act as the Connecting
Point between central government and
lrfs
so um in the preparedness phase Red's
role is to act as a critical friend of
local planners
um to check that they uh are asking
themselves the right question because
the accountability for planning lies
with them
share with them and point them in the
direction of guidance that's been issued
so that they can understand that
to ensure that they understand the
national risk registers that are issued
and then of course local planners then
have to make their own Community risk
registers and to help local Partners
identify risks
in a response phase
um Reds interaction
would build on that sort of relationship
and effectively they would act as a
communicator between the local lrf and
the center highlighting where there are
issues that need to be resolved and
facilitating the transfer of information
between central and local for the
avoidance of Doubt red has no role in
assuring the local plan because the
local plan is the responsibility of the
local responders and legislation and
accountability very clearly sits there
all right
the the identity of the the person that
sits in red who communicates at a local
level is that person called a resilience
advisor they are called a resilience
advisor when they're planning and
Advising yes right and in the event of
um
of of a response period if you like does
the name of that person change to become
a local a government liaison officer
they do and the reason for the change of
name is literally that they turn into a
function where they are liaising very
proactively between the local and the
national to make sure messages get
through and to make sure they're helping
to solve problems and handing things to
lead departments and things where it's
needed is it more often than not the
case that that person is the same person
the resilience advisor is the same
person as the government liaison officer
um
often and usually we may come on to this
later at points where the whole
country's systems are activated as in a
pandemic response we had to work
um on shift bases and and with a bit
more variety but normally we would try
for as much continuity as is possible
all right
do you think it's perhaps
unnecessary and a little confusing that
the name of that person changes or the
title of that person changes or do you
think it's helpful I think for people
who work in the system they understand
absolutely how these systems work
in terms of oversight and Assurance
you've explained why red does not hold
a responsibility of assuring that the
local plans are in place Etc do you
think it would help if red did have that
level of assurance and accountability to
to
um to provide at that level
comfort that the the local plans are
dealing with the national risks
appropriately
um
I I think it potentially could be quite
confusing done in that way because
um
what we are trying to achieve in in red
is a situation where red supports the
local people who are accountable for
planning and helped them in a supportive
Collegiate way to assure themselves that
they are at an appropriate level of
preparedness
um and that accountability and the
clarity of that accountability is
relatively important I think
um
I would say two additional things if you
would let me the first I think is that
um
that's not the same as saying that red
disengages from the process of local
plans and local risk assessments
if I can take an example in
pandemic preparedness
um
we may come on to it later I mean red
has participated in a lot of the
exercises over the years that have been
important in pandemic preparedness but
we've also taken steps
um over the years I mean in December
2017 we interviewed all our refs and
said I think 35 38 and asked them about
their levels of preparedness fed back
what they said
um to central government departments to
Aid that communication where does
additionally run workshops for lrs to
attend and had a central government
Partners there as well so that they
could work together on uh the issues
that needed to be grappled with in terms
of planning for a pandemic
um it readable for facilitated a sort of
local resilience Forum engagement group
to work through particular issues with
central government Partners so although
they're not assuring
um local plans whatsoever
Reds interlocutor role when it's a major
risk such as pandemic planning
um Extended as far as facilitating the
communication in those sort of joined up
ways between local and National
and the second thing to say I think is
just that we we do recognize
that lrfs need to be able to assure
themselves and have good accountability
locally for their own plans
and although I believe it wasn't set out
in my witness statement because it
post-dates it and we have made some
further announcements about further work
on that right thank you
and
at the heart of the system is the
principle of subsidiarity is that right
correct and and can you explain to us
what Red's approach is to that and how
it ensures that that matters Cascade
down in the way that that principle
expects
well the principle of subsidiarity is
that decisions should be taken at the
lowest possible level and coordination
should happen at the at the lowest
necessary level
um
in in general Red's approach is
therefore to make sure that information
is cascaded down
um if I can use that terminology to
local resilience for her so to give you
an example red will have facilitated
events following workshops and things
following few of the National Security
risk assessment to make sure that every
lrf in the country understood that and
could dock that into their plans
Red's General approach is to share as
much information as is possible with
local resilience for it we do that
um depending on the security of the
information and also
um the sign off of the lead government
department but we have a very strong
culture of sharing with local colleagues
and in relation to a pandemic
the preparedness here really was whole
system
so Red's approach to subsidiarity there
was to dock into the central structures
which you'll have heard a lot about the
pan flu Readiness boards and
structures like that
um and to convey there what local
resilience Forum were saying and then to
facilitate the flow of information into
local resilience forums to be part of
joint exercising locally and nationally
and to facilitate the flow of messages
back up and down through the system
so I think in summary it is an approach
based on subsidiarity it is just a whole
system approach when planning for a
pandemic because some elements of it
involve National decision making and
some quite rightly
either lrf level or more local decision
making because it's even more local than
that it is local Partners who know their
communities and we know that local
planners are very good at dealing with
their communities well let's have a look
at a couple of documents please the
first is a report from the c19 national
foresight group entitled covid-19
pandemic third interim operational
review thank you now this is dated
October of 2020 so it's outside of our
um of our module one time period but I I
want to look at page 22 please because
it it sets out some concerns that were
felt by from delegates if we can
highlight the second paragraph there
please
This was
um a group that had gathered evidence
from all but one
um local resilience forum and it said
delegates report that they did not feel
understood or trusted by central
government and ministers they have
reported that ministers in some
government departments still do not
understand what local resilience forums
and
scgs are what these structures can and
cannot do and what the differences
between an lrf and an scg is that a
strategic commissioning group
an sdg coordination coordination group
this hampers the ability to integrate
the national and local approach as the
expectations from the national decision
makers are misplaced and misaligned with
the Civil contingencies Frameworks or
guidance materials or incorrectly framed
or include incorrect details
you recognize Miss Francis
um
so I was aware of this work being done
at the time and indeed read attended
some of the sessions to hear firsthand
because it was important to learn from
practitioners and what they were feeling
at the time
um
I I think not not to
deflect the query you're making but like
this is October 2020 yes and I think
quite a lot of what we're hearing from
delegates here is
um their reflection on on evolution
during the pandemic and how they felt
certain things were going
um
the distinction between an lrf and an
scg
um is of course important in operational
work what is the difference the
distinction is is literally that an lrf
is the group that brings together all of
the category one responders but when you
go into response you need a strategic
group that is just running the response
and that is designated by the lrf that
is the the scg to avoid a huge number of
letters creeping in in central
government I think possibly sometimes
people refer to lrs when they meant scgs
but I don't think that would have meant
that central government departments
didn't understand what an lrf was or
indeed an scg
um I think this question about feelings
of trust between central government and
ministers
um is one that one really has to act ask
local Partners about we often heard from
local partners that they wanted to
um have advanced notice of decisions
that were being taken um and sometimes
they asked about the sharing of
information on a timely way I think some
of that is coming out here and from a
red perspective
um
and indeed a wider departmental
perspective we shared material when it
was authorized to be shared when
decisions have been taken and so on so
forth
all right we can take that down please
and let's replace it with one double
seven eight zero three which is the
witness statement of Mark Lloyd from the
local government Association he's going
to be coming to give evidence to the
inquiry at a later date
could we go to page 51 and have a look
at paragraph 199 please
thank you
the lga's view is that in a number of
cases the principle this is of
subsidiarity is not currently being
applied affected areas areas I'm so
sorry in a number of areas the principle
is not currently being applied
effectively subsidiarity implies that
local agencies are trusted equal
Partners in emergency preparedness and
response which inappropriate
circumstances are empowered to lead
local resilience work however there are
a number of examples of practice
suggesting otherwise and if we could
read on to the next paragraph please
as noted a persistent issue which has
undermined trust and therefore the
principle of subsidiarity has been the
extent of central government's
willingness to share information with
local Partners there have been repeated
challenges with central government
sharing intelligence and information
about National risks for examples
planning assumptions reasonable worst
case scenarios on a limited basis or not
at all thereby undermining the ability
of local areas to undertake timely and
informed local planning thank you
it appears from from what Mark Lloyd has
to say it's certainly in those two
paragraphs is that there was a lack of
sharing of information or certainly a
perception at the local level of not
being fully informed about the national
risk assessment and what lay behind it
do you agree
Miss Francis that if the risk
assessments at a local level are going
to be meaningful and adequate there
needs to be an understanding of the
assumptions that are being used at a
national level to perform the national
risk assessment
so the national risk security assessment
is shared with every lrf in England
there are elements of it that can be
secure and they can be accessed through
secure routes
lrfs themselves nominate who has access
to that information
um
so when we use the lrf to Cascade that
information
because it is the named
in civil contingencies approaches in
legislation just so that I I understand
it correctly that there is a a
confidential there's a secret part of
the National Security risk assessment
isn't there there's a a an element of it
which is not public facing and are you
suggesting that in relation to that part
of the assessment process there is a
facility whereby the local resilience
Forum can have access to that but it
requires the nomination of a person
presumably who has security clearance to
do that so my understanding is that the
nsra is shared with esri lrf in the
country and certainly in 2019 when it
was updated red and the CCS run a series
of events with local resilience for it
so that they understood changes to the
NS nsra sorry and appreciated how that
could affect them
um
that is not the same as saying that
every local partner saw the nsra or the
uh Associated documents and lrf would
each have had to decide who had access
to that material
um and my understanding is that the
areas that are more secure are treated
in a more secure way but it would have
been for the lrf to determine who saw
that and I would certainly expect to
keep people to have seen the key
documentation so does it surprise you
that that Mr Lloyd's
opinion appears to be that there have
been repeated challenges about the
sharing of information I think that he's
making two points if I read this right
so the first is around the national risk
assessments where as I said it was
shared in the appropriate way down the
appropriate routes the second point I
think he's making is a general question
about whether information more widely
was shared
um
and I think I say two things here I mean
the first is that before the pandemic
local planners had the same
um
epidemiological uh sort of assumptions
that were there in all of the all of the
documentation as National planners were
using from the 2011 and 2013
documentation
um
and we're working using the same
planning Frameworks
um as central government planners
um
and I think
we also shared with them updated covered
material when it was available
so I I understand that local partners
and we did hear local Partners saying
are you sharing as much as you can but I
think in terms of pandemic preparation
the basic building blocks were all
common across Central and national
government the exercises that we were
doing were on common bases and same for
planners I would say that in the
pandemic things moved at PACE and
sometimes that may have led local
planners to say could you not have told
this this earlier totally accept that
that's absolutely something we heard but
in terms of of preparedness and and the
the national risk assessment and and the
ability of of that to be carried forward
and cascading down to a local level do
you think there is a disconnect between
what happens at a national and a local
level or are you confident that that
there is sufficient
quality of information flowing from the
top to the bottom
well I think if we set out the national
risk assessments we hold a series of
events to explain the changes and then
lrfs are required and I think do
understand what's in the National risk
assessments
but that that's acceptable I think they
then need to work out at a local level
and this can be challenging actually how
the local community risk assessment
works because you may have a part of the
country which has a different balance of
risk assessment to another for entirely
legitimate reasons
um maybe it's subjectable flooding than
another part of the country or something
we see those sorts of variations but yes
I think local planners had those
framework pieces
what are Regional resilience teams
so are you referring to the arrangements
which were in place before red started
not a department yes yes
um
so
before 2011 yes
government was structured in a different
way and there were a series of
government offices across England
um in that context uh there are a series
of regional resilience teams and they
were cabinet office teams who reported
directly into the cabinet office and
they did what the name suggests actually
a very similar function to that which
red performs
um and has performed since 2011. but
spread out across the country yes
exactly located in those government
offices which no longer exist and it
didn't adapt to 2011.
and um
it were to be suggested that
consideration perhaps should be given to
the reinstatement of regional resilience
teams to add
an additional level of
assistance and perhaps
combined with a level of assurance
between central and local government do
you think that that's an idea that's
worth considering
um there are very different views around
the country on the regional
situation
and I think that we think that the
regional position is more complex than
in resilience terms than existed prior
to 2011.
um to explain that a little bit more
there are some parts of the country
where the collaboration jointly between
resilience planners on the old Regional
footprint still continues to feel
relatively natural if I can put it that
way so to draw an example the northeast
or the Southwest the lrfs in those areas
tend to work jointly in a way that is
very close to the original Regional
footprint and red works with them on
that basis as well if they want to work
like that we support them on that basis
but there are other parts of the country
where that geography doesn't feel so
natural maybe because there's a very
rural area next to a very urban area and
the connection there just feels less
significant than maybe other structural
connections so
red Works in a way that we support
collaboration across different lrfs in
the way that works but whatever the task
that needs to be done so if I can give
you an example
in preparations for the possibility of
leaving the EU is no deal we worked with
different lrfs across the country who
had ports and airports and clearly they
weren't all in one region but they
shared a common set of issues that they
needed to deal with and so we would Flex
our approach that way
um I should just have one more point
which is that red does work on a
regional basis we have four Regional
Offices right
um at various times it's been four or
five but all of the workshops that we've
run in pandemic planning
um
for example are workshops in I think
it's in early 2018 were run in four
locations so that if connections needed
to be made on the regional basis we were
facilitating that right so so from what
you have said red takes the issue that's
been raised considers the area in which
it's being raised and prepares and
presents a suitable solution and and
it's a it's got flexibility within the
organization in order to be able to do
that that is a very good way of putting
it thank you thank you very much
and I want to move on to resources now
please
um the inquiry will hear that in terms
of
Local Government funding and there were
real terms reductions over the period of
time that that this inquiry is is
involved in and up to in some cases 57
that evidence is going to be coming from
Mr Lloyd
and that
however large the reduction was there
was a significant amount of concern at a
local government level as to whether or
not there was sufficient
resource in order to be able to carry
out proper preparation for any civil
emergency happening
did you witness the impact of reduction
in funding or changes in funding in your
day-to-day relationship with local
government
can I correct one thing for the record
yes please
um I think you said that there was a 57
reduction in local government budgets
um I I what I what I intended to say was
that the councils had their core funding
from central government reduced and in
some areas that amounted to a real terms
reduction of 57 percent I think I think
quote from Mark Lloyd's witness
statement that's exactly where it's
important for the uh the the inquiry to
understand
um that that is not a measure of the
resources available to local government
particularly because it doesn't include
resources from council tax Mark Lloyd in
his witness statement does make
reference to another figure which is
drawn from the National Audit office and
I would strongly recommend that we use
that one because it represents a
holistic view of resources for councils
um it's at paragraph 287 in multiple
do you agree that there was a reduction
absolutely
absolutely and my question was
did you witness any impact of of that
reduction in your day-to-day work with
um local government
um so there was definitely a really
significant reduction in local
government resources in the 2010s as
part of the wider government approach
to fiscal policy
what I've witnessed varies a lot between
different councils
um
and it's hard to draw simple conclusions
about the budget reductions and
preparedness for a pandemic actually
that's firstly I think because
councils make their own decisions about
what they're going to prioritize within
the statutory framework and so they will
and naturally have looked at
um
where they had statutory
responsibilities like to plan for
emergencies and for big Public Services
which were critical and will have
formed a view about what was necessary
um
because they take different locally
based decisions as well they also take
quite different strategies
and it's hard to generalize and they're
quite good and have been very effective
organizations working
in a creative way to get out
efficiencies over this era so I would
say
I've seen council's capacity being
affected that is the case I've also seen
them working in a very efficient way
through different reductions
at a overall level when you look at the
choices they've made on services like
adult social care and Children's
Services they've tended
try to uphold the expenditure in those
areas
um and make reductions elsewhere
um
and yes I don't think you can draw quite
a straight line from the resourcing
question to their capability and their
their planning because they've seen
quite resilient organizations to me and
quite adaptable and they were in the
pandemic in your witness statement you
make reference to Best Value Duty what
does that mean
um there's a duty in legislation that
councils have regard to efficiency and
economy and Improvement
which is a requirement on all councils
essentially to govern themselves well
and to continue with due regard
to those principles they
the best value principle has been used
when councils are in severe difficulty
but it's a relatively unusual
context relatively unusual intervention
to make on a best value grounds most
councils govern themselves exceptionally
well and uh are very effective at
managing the sort of resource pressure
do you think that at the the present
time the subsidiarity model is still
capable of working effectively given the
level of funding that that local
government has
absolutely right
other issues relating to the
relationship between red and the local
government uh but both local authorities
and local resilience forums
would it assist in the planning that
they have to do for civil emergencies
for there to be one single repository of
material that they need to consider that
there's the the inquiry has received
information that that there isn't at
present a single repository for Relevant
guidance and information on emergency
preparedness and that that
consideration of creating that is is
something that should happen
so the cabinet office hold
um
a system called resilience direct which
can be accessed by lrfs
um
and some of the guidance is also
available on public websites we have
heard exactly the same feedback from
local planners and you will have seen in
some of our documentation attached to my
witness statement
um that's reflected in some of that
feedback
the inquiries also heard that
in the main part guidance
um that that reflects upon all civil
emergencies but in particular pandemic
planning did not
um cover the issue of
non-pharmaceutical interventions
um
do you think that going forwards that is
something that the involvement of that
in in planning documents and guidance
given to those in charge of local
government about non-pharmaceutical
interventions would be a welcome
addition
um
so local planners for the pandemic we're
using the same
planning guidance documents and the same
assumptions as National
um
and and thus as you'll have heard from
other Witnesses and you'll have seen
from the published material there were
elements in there and what happened in
the pandemic that weren't included in
there yes um
in terms of what should be in a planning
document for pandemic whether flu or
otherwise I would absolutely defer to
the Department of Health and Social care
because they are the lead government
Department in defining what should be
included in that
so I hope that answers your question
um
the work there were gaps in terms of the
comparability of what we were planning
for and what ultimately happened
they had the same information as central
government departments and I would
absolutely defer to DH
when one considers that
um particularly taking into account the
the model or the the principle of
subsidiarity that it is those people on
the ground acting locally following
plans and guidance locally that are in
the greatest need of of practical
guidance then it is imperative is it not
that that the guidance that they follow
includes the practical application of
things like non-pharmaceutical
interventions it's
absolutely necessary that the plans that
everyone is following are as close as
can be reasonably expected to be what is
likely to happen and that everybody has
a shared understanding of that and that
in exercising and in reflecting on
exercises and in workshopping things we
are talking about the same thing whether
a national or local level
I'd finally like to ask you about the
vulnerable
and what level of
um involvement planning and guidance has
had in terms of identifying
those who are the most vulnerable in
society and how they need to be
um
accounted for in terms of planning and
also in terms of any response to a civil
emergency
you send your witness statement that red
engages with voluntary community and
social Enterprise Partners in
preparedness response and Recovery
planning this is primarily through lrf
engagement where vcse partners are core
Partners within individual lrfs can you
explain to us please how that works
yes certainly so
um
the department is not the lead
Department in national government
in terms of overall relationship with
the voluntary and Community sector but
it is absolutely critical to emergency
preparedness and response that the
voluntary and Community sector are part
of that
um the guidance that sets out how lrfs
should work stipulates that
um lrs should be expected to work with
volunteering organizations at the right
footprint
and so the way that we support uh
lrs on that it is simply to make sure
that they are aware of that guidance and
to to make sure they Factor it in
um I think more precisely in terms of
preparing
from Red if I can give you an example at
the national level
we try and make sure we have some
connections with lead VCS organizations
so for example the British Red Cross has
attended or twice yearly lrf's chairs
um a conference
on very regular occasions and is a a
regular attendee and invitee
um but then we Channel most of our work
with the BCS simply by looking at the
lrf and what the lrf is doing
um
to elaborate yet further
when we're in response and indeed in
planning we often find that the lrf area
itself is quite a large footprint for
engaging with charities
so in the pandemic a lot of very kind
people gave of their time and effort and
they did so that what we described as a
hyper local level so often that was
corralled and organized by local
authorities who themselves would then be
part of the lrf structure so there's
some engagement by us at the national
level but our primary engagement with
the VCS is to ask lrs to do that and
then we absolutely acknowledge that
local authorities and even smaller
partners are are working collaboratively
with the BCS all right well you
mentioned the British Red Cross and so
I'd like to display part of the witness
statement that we have from Mr Adamson
who's the chief executive there it's at
one eight two six one three and if we
can go to page 10 please and look at
paragraph 43 thank you
the British Red Cross has long believed
that increased engagement between the
ccs and the voluntary sector would be
beneficial for the UK's emergency
preparedness
it is in that context that in 2019 the
British Red Cross and other voluntary
organizations sought to engage with the
CCS our Focus was on seeking to develop
a strategy with the government for the
voluntary sector to react to a range of
emergencies based on the lessons learned
from responding to the multiple
emergency events of 2017.
the intention was for the voluntary
sector to offer something more than the
gold and silver and bronze model which
usually dominates emergency responses in
particular to focus on the human aspects
of recovery that are sometimes forgotten
the experience was somewhat dispiriting
and there appeared to be a lack of
curiosity on the part of the CCS
regarding what the voluntary sector
could provide
and further down please I had also
previously approached red in 2018 and
received a more positive response
including a proposed approach for the
CCS for a three-way meeting however this
meeting did not materialize
could more be done Miss Francis to
engage with the voluntary sector and to
ensure that so far as both planning and
response is concerned those most
vulnerable in society and who require
the services and assistance from the
voluntary sector are engaged with both
both at a national and also at a level
at which red was and and is existing
so I just I mean a lot of what you've
just read out is in relation to CCS not
red
um uh I don't know about the particular
meeting that my God and Sons alluding to
in in paragraph 44. but but forgive me
you you were you were talking in in your
previous answer about engagement at a
national level with with ccs
between ccs and the no I was talking
about engagement at National level
primarily between red and the British
Red Cross but I also noted that the
British Red Cross often attended a joint
our joint uh lrf chairs uh called with
just joint with ccs there
um I mean I I think that there's always
more to be done working with the
voluntary and Community sector it has an
incredibly distinct and important role
it is exactly as my Collections and
notes not the same as the role that is
provided through gold silver bronze
structures
um so I accept his feedback that
um local resilience Partners whether
that be an lrf or other for a
um
can continue to build uh their
connections with the BCS I also noted in
his witness statement that he talked
about progress that had been made about
Integrations with the BCS
um over the course of the pandemic which
seemed to me to be positive and were led
by the lead government department for
the DC for the VCS in terms of Red's
engagement with the VCS um
as I've said the national engagement in
the lrf's uh chairs
Forum has been the Principal one
um and we have looked across the sector
at how people are engaging with the BCS
to see if we can learn any lessons or
take any cues from that we haven't yet
move forward with the workbook because
if red is is expecting to be able to
rely upon the British Red Cross and
other organizations within the the VCS
in the event of a response to a civil
emergency and that is likely to to make
more of an impact if the VCS it has also
been engaged in the preparation isn't it
red is asking local responders but red
is acting as a communicator between
central and local government instructors
red is asking
that local responders who are
responsible in legislation are content
that they have plans
and
the cabinet office guidance which is
very sensible expects lrfs to have good
connections with the BCS I completely
agree that good connections with the BCS
is a vital part of the mixture part of
the recipe of good response and good
planning
um I'm not sure I can go very much
beyond that all right our recent
Publications on this Express a desire to
integrate preparedness and response more
closely with communities which of course
is in part about the VCS though not
entirely thank you very much would you
excuse my back
my lady there are no questions which for
which permission has been granted and so
that concludes Miss francis's evidence
well I think we've all had enough
acronyms for one day I'm sorry about
that yes it's not your fault I'm afraid
it's systemic yes
um and then it was enough acronyms for a
lifetime but I fear it's not thank you
very much indeed for your health and
responses thank you
thank you right
um as far as next week is concerned
obviously we're not sitting tomorrow
it's a Friday we don't normally sit on a
Friday we had hoped to sit Monday
morning but for various reasons it
hasn't proved possible so I will next it
again at two o'clock Monday afternoon
thank you my lady thank you
all right